ARE THESE GENTLEMEN.
I THINK. WE TOOK WE LIKE AS A
COURTESY TO WAIT UNTIL WE HAVE A
MEMBER OF HIS PARTY BY FLEAS ON
HIS WAY OUT OF RESPECT. TO
EVERYONE ELSE LET'S HEAR
INCLUDING A MEMBER. WHO'S
UNPREPARED TO PRESENT DOUBLE GO
AHEAD PROCEED AS A SUB COMMITTEE
OF THE WHOLE.
WELCOME TO OUR FIRST.
AND HOPEFULLY.
ARE ONLY HEARING AT LEAST ON
ASSEMBLY SIDE RIGHT FOR A.
WHO FOR THE COMMITTEE ON AGING
AND LONG TERM CARE?
?
NO I THINK THAT MANY OF YOU KNOW
THAT.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE SEVERAL
MONTHS THAT WE HAD.
DURING THE FALL OF HELD THREE
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS.
AROUND THE STATE.
AND THE FIRST WOMAN SALAS A
FOCUS ON LONG TERM CARE ISSUES
SECOND WAS A SAN DIEGO FOCUS ON
HOUSING AND HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY AND HOW WE CAN
KEEP OUR. AGING COMMUNITY A
SENIORS AGING AT HOME.
END OF THE THIRD A HEARING WAS
LOS ANGELES. OUR FOCUS MUCH ON
WHAT POTENTIAL IMPACTS OF WOULD
BE FROM FEDERAL A CUT SAID AT
LEAST EVEN TO THIS DAY HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED.
THAT WOULD WITH QUITE WELL
WITHOUT REGULARITY.
IN WASHINGTON DC.
I THINK THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN REDUCED
BY NUMBER OF COLLEAGUES
INCLUDING MYSELF. THAT ADDRESS A
WIDE RANGE OF ISSUES THAT WERE
UP TO GLEANED FROM THOSE
HEARINGS AND ISA ONE EXPRESS MY
GRATITUDE A NUMBER OF YOU THAT
ARE HERE. THAT WERE THERE AT
THOSE HEARINGS SAW SOME OF YOU
AT ALL THREE OF THEM.
I WANT TO. THINK A. VERY AND I
WE HAVE MY STAFF FOR HELPING
MAKE THOSE HEARINGS PRODUCTIVE
IMPOSSIBLE AS WELL AS GUILTY OF
FROM THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE. FOUR
OF HER ENGAGEMENT AS WELL.
THE SPEAKER IS BEEN VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT WE CAN DO TO CONTINUE
TO HELP. OUR AGING LONG TERM
CARE COMMUNITY AND WE. ALL KNOW
THAT.
MUCH OF WHAT MUCH OF THE
CONDITIONS WERE IN OUR CRISIS
MODE IN TERMS OF OUR ABILITY TO
KICK TAKE CARE. OF OUR QUICKLY
OF AGING POPULATION WITH A LACK
OF RESOURCES AND FUNDS AND SO. I
THINK WE HAVE TO WORK ON THAT.
COLLECTIVELY WORK ON THAT
TOGETHER.
AND SO I'M GRATEFUL TO THE
MEMBERS WHO HAVE INTRODUCED
BILLS WILL BE HEARING TODAY I
THINK THEY'VE. THE COVER A WIDE
RANGE ISSUES. REGARDING.
ARE THE SENIOR AND AND DISABLED
POPULATION. AND I'M HOPEFUL.
MODE THAT THEY WILL GO UP SOME
WAYS INTO RESOLVING SOME OF THE
ISSUES SOME OF THE MANY ISSUES
THAT WE FACE IS A STATE.
SO WITH THAT.
I'D LIKE TO.
.
COLUMN ó AND WE HAVE A VICE
CHAIR VOEPEL HERE'S A THANK YOU.
THINK NO PROBLEM THANKS FOR
HOSTING OVER HERE.
AND SO.
.
THE IN TERMS HOW TEST WILL BE
TAKEN UP AUTHOR PRESENTS WILL
TAKE TESTIMONY AS TIME PERMITS.
FIVE YOU CAN LIMIT.
MOVED WITNESSES TO TO IF YOU
POPPED OUT THREE. THE THAT'LL BE
FINE BUT TRY TO LIMIT THE AMOUNT
OF TIME.
AGAIN THAT'S FOR EACH SIDE AND.
YOU NOBLE WILL GIVE EQUAL TIME
IF THERE IS OPPOSITION THAT
SPEAKS AS WELL. FOR ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT OPPOSITION PLEASE JUST
STATE YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
BALK. UMBER TURN THE MIKE ON FOR
YOU UP WHEN THAT THAT TIME
HOWEVER WE GET TO THAT POINT.
SO I LIKE TO START BY INVITING
US AMBER BECAUSE ACOSTA UP.
I'M HERE BECAUSE OF ME GOING IN
FILE ITEM ORDER A GIVEN THAT.
SOMEONE TOSSES OTHERS ONLY WHEN
HERE WILL TAKE NUMBER THREE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
.
WHEN WE FIRST OPENED THE DOORS.
AB TWENTY ONE OH ONE REGARDING
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS AN
OF OUR VOLUNTEER WORK FORCE
SUMMER ACOSTA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MISTER VICE CHAIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT AB TWENTY
ONE OWNED ONE A BEFORE I BEGIN I
WILL BE TAKING THE CLARIFYING
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS UP FOR THE
BILL'S DESCRIBED IN THE
ANALYSIS.
AB TWENTY ONE NO ONE WILL
ESTABLISH A WORKFORCE FOR THE
ELDERLY WORKING WITH THE CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS TO
PROVIDE RESPITE CARE. TO THOSE
IN NEED OF IN HOME CARE FROM LOW
AND MIDDLE INCOME FAMILIES THAT
ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR H. SS.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE MORE THAN
FOUR MILLION UNPAID FAMILY CARE
GIVERS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE PP I SEE IS ESTIMATED THAT
BY TWENTY THIRTY THE NUMBER OF
SENIORS IN NEED OF IN HOME CARE
SERVICES WILL HAVE DOUBLED TO
OVER NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND.
THIS NUMBER DOES NOT TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THOSE WILL BE IN NURSING
HOMES SOMETHING THAT MOST MIDDLE
AND LOW INCOME FAMILIES CANNOT
AFFORD.
THE COST FOR ASSISTED LIVING
FACILITIES AND NURSING HOMES
CONSUMERS SIXTY NINE POINT SEVEN
PERCENT. AND ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY ONE PERCENT RESPECTIVELY
OF THE MEDIAN ANNUAL INCOME OF
CALIFORNIANS SOMETHING THAT
MEDICARE AND MEDICAID HOW ARE
UNABLE TO COVER EFFECTIVELY.
THIS BILL WILL UTILIZE THE
EXISTING STRUCTURE OF THE SEE
OUR SEASON WILL ADD ON TO THEIR
CAPABILITIES BY CREATING AN
INCENTIVE BASED PILOT PROGRAM
FOR YOUNG ADULTS.
IDEALLY THE PROGRAM WILL BE
GEARED FOR COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO
WERE INTERESTED IN PURSUING A
CAREER IN THE HEALTHCARE FIELD
BY PROMOTE PROVIDING EDUCATIONAL
BENEFITS. AS WELL AS A MONTHLY
STIPEND.
THIS PROGRAM WILL ACT AS A
TUNNEL BETWEEN SCHOOL AND THE
RESPITE CARE FIELD FOR STUDENTS
TO GAIN REAL WORLD EXPERIENCE.
ENCOURAGE THEM TO GO INTO A
FIELD THAT IS EXTREMELY DEPLETED
AND IN NEED OF CARE GIVERS.
ADDITIONALLY THIS IS AN OPTIONAL
PILOT PROGRAM WHICH WILL PROVIDE
US WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO BEST SERVE
THOSE IN NEED OF CARE.
I HAVE NEEDS NEED HOLLIS CITY
AND HAVE.
I HOPE I GOT THAT RIGHT WITH ME
TODAY EVEN THOUGH WE WERE HEARST
IT AT LEAST TWICE I THINK.
WITH ME TODAY REPRESENTING THE
SPONSOR THE YOUTH MOVEMENT
AGAINST ALZHEIMER'S.
AND I HAD ANOTHER.
THE EXPERT WITNESS BUT GET TOOK
A SIX SO ME HOW MIGHT COVER
APPOINTED TO OF OF THERE'S. I
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
CONSIDERATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
S. KNOW THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE INTRODUCTION
AND THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IS AYE AYE ACOSTA AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA FOR THEIR
AUTHORSHIP BUT THIS BILL. I'M
CHAIR KALRA AND ESTEEMED MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ASKING MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE.
I HAVE MY NAME IS THE HOUSE I
DO IF I AM THE ORIGINATOR OF
THIS BILL AND ASPIRING PHYSICIAN
AND I SERVE HIGHS THE CEO AND
COFOUNDER OF THE YOUTH MOVEMENT
AGAINST ALZHEIMER'S. AND
NONPROFIT THAT STARTED RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND HAS GROWN
TO ENGAGING FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS AYE AND IS NOW THE
NATION'S LEADER AND YOU ADVOCACY
FOR THIS DISEASE.
WE AS STUDENTS ARE.
ARE CONCERNED OF THE COST OF
CARE WILL HOW GROW MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID IN THE AN UPCOMING
DECADES WE'RE SCARED THAT OUR
PARENTS ARE RETIRING INTO A
SOCIETY THAT CANNOT GUARANTEE
THEM ADEQUATE HOUSING IN CARE.
AND AS MILLENNIALS WE ARE
INTERESTED IN VOTING FOR LONG
TERM SOLUTIONS TO OUR GLOBAL
CHALLENGES THAT IF NOT ADDRESS
NOW WILL BE UNIVERSALLY
IMPACTFUL AS WE REACH OUR
FORTIES AND FIFTIES.
AND TODAY WE'RE CREATING JUST
SUCH A SOLUTION.
AB TWO ONE NO ONE CALLS FOR THE
CREATION OF A CALIFORNIA CARE
CORPSE AT TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATION ACROSS FIVE
YEARS. TO INCENTIVIZE.
AND THAT THAT INCENTIVIZE IS
HIGH SCHOOL AND COLLEGE
GRADUATES TO PROVIDE FULL TIME
CARE TO A SENIOR WITH COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENT.
IN JUST ONE BILL WE ARE ABLE TO.
PROVIDE.
IT TO ADD VALUE TO MANY
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS
FOR YOUNG INDIVIDUALS LIKE
MYSELF THIS PROVIDES A.
UNIQUE LIFE PERSPECTIVE AND AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DEVELOP SKILLS TO
WORK WITH OUR GROWING AGING
POPULATION.
FOR CURRENT FAMILY CAREGIVERS AN
OVERWHELMING AMOUNT WHICH ARE
DEALING WITH DEPRESSION THIS
OFFERS A MUCH NEEDED BREAK.
AND FOR THOSE WITH THE DISEASE.
THIS OFFERS A YOUNG INDIVIDUAL
FULL OF SPIRIT AND ENERGY TO
IMPROVE QUALITY OF LIFE.
FOR CALIFORNIA AND OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
WE ARE ABLE TO ALLEVIATE THE
NEED FOR MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES
AND ARE LESSEN THE NEED FOR
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES. AND
LOWER.
YEAH AND.
ALLOW CAREGIVERS TO REENTER THE
WORKFORCE
IF FIFTY PERCENT OF RECIPIENTS
OF THIS PROGRAM ARE ABLE TO GO
BACK TO WORK AT A MEDIAN SALARY
WE WILL BE ABLE TO PAY BACK THE
COST OF THIS PILOT IN TEN
PERCENT. THROUGH TAXES ALONE.
SO HOW DO WE KNOW THAT WE WILL
BE ABLE TO BENEFIT ALL THESE
PARTIES WILL BECAUSE MY
NONPROFIT OPERATES AN
INTERGENERATIONAL SOCIAL
ENTERPRISE AT THE THAT IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE UNIVERSITY
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THAT WAS
LAUNCHED AFTER A TWO YEAR PILOT
AT UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA LOS
ANGELES.
WE TRAIN COLLEGE STUDENT
VOLUNTEERS TO PROVIDE.
AND PARTNER THEM WITH OLDER
ADULTS WITH EARLY TO MID STAGE
DEMENTIA IN A COMMUNITY BASED
SETTING. FOR SIX HOURS A WEEK
DURING WHICH TIME THE CARE
GIVERS GET A BREAK WE HAVE
QUANTIFIABLE DATA TO SHOW
BENEFITS TO ALL PARTIES.
THIS OUR IT DID THIS PROGRAM I
THINK IS.
IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
TO OUR STATE TO SHOW THAT ONCE
AGAIN WE ARE LEADING BY EXAMPLE
JUST LIKE CALIFORNIA DID IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR THROUGH THE
CURATION OF THE CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS. AND DID AGAIN
IN TWO THOUSAND TWO THROUGH THE
PAID FAMILY LEAVE ACT.
WE AS A STATE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW THAT WE KNOW
THAT AMERICA'S CARE GIVERS ARE
UNSUNG HEROES AND THAT WE AS A
STATE INNOVATE WITH THE
FOUNDATION IN COMPASSION. AND
ONE THAT.
DOT IS PREPARING FOR TOMORROW'S
WORKFORCE.
I AT ENCOURAGE THAT THE CHAIR
AND THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO SEE THIS BILL
THROUGH.
AND JOIN OUR ORGANIZATION'S
VISION AS WE WORK TOGETHER TO
CREATE A FUTURE WORTH
REMEMBERING THANK YOU.
IF YOU.
ANY OTHER OF THE WITNESSES
SUPPORT.
OR ANY OTHER FULL OF FOLKS NOT
IS A SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NOW
CALLED THE TEARS HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION
AND I AM HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE ONE.
I BEFORE BUT OF THE MOVE FOR
LIKE TO HAVE. A QUORUM
ESTABLISHED.
KALRA.
THERE.
VOEPEL.
YOU.
ALLEN.
CABALLERO.
GIPSON.
GLORIA.
RUBIO.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM ESTABLISHED IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
I'M SUPPORT I APOLOGIZE OUR
HOUSE HAD CAN GET IN THAT ROOM
MY CANNELLA REPRESENTING ON
ALZHEIMER'S GREATER LOS ANGELES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT. IF NOT
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
AND WE WILL BRING IT BACK.
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS OR MOTIONS.
CHECK.
I WAS A U. S. NAVY SAILOR FOR
ALMOST NINE YEARS
SAILORS CHECK AGAIN ONE WHERE
MUSTARD ON STATION AND WITH YOU
KNOW. THAT'S A NAVAL HER YEAH.
SO THE CLARIFYING AMENDMENT
EQUIPMENT.
.
I THINK IF THERE IS A A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
AND NO FOR THE COLLEGE LIKE TO
CLOSE WHAT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE BOTH THANK YOU FOR THE.
MOTION THE SECOND BY THE
COMMITTEE AND NAP APPRECIATE NOT
ABOUT.
ALRIGHT WELL THERE IS AN AYE
RECOMMENDATION WITH THE
AMENDMENTS AND AND THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY GLORIA
SECOND ABOUT CABALLERO.
TAKE PLEASE TAKE A VOTE ON THE
VOTE.
KALRA AYE KALRA AYE.
VOEPEL AYE AYE.
VOEPEL I.
OUTLINE SKEWS ME ALLEN.
CABALLERO BY.
CABALLERO AYE GIPSON.
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE RUBIO.
ALRIGHT SO THAT BILL DOES PASS
TO ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR.
UP WE HAVE UP FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB TWENTY TWENTY FIVE SUMMER
MAIENSCHEIN.
EVEN IF WE GET THANK YOU ARE
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BEFORE I BEGIN I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
WORK. I LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS.
AS WELL AS LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL
ON THE LANGUAGE OF THE BILL. AT
TO ENSURE THE TECHNICAL ASPECTS
ARE DRESSED AS A BILL PROGRESSES
AB TWENTYTWENTY FIVE WOULD
ENACT THE ELDERS LIVING WITH
DIGNITY EMPATHY RESPECT AND
SUPPORT ELDERS BOND ACT. WHICH
PROVIDE FOR A BOND ISSUE OF TWO
ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
CONSTRUCTION AND OR RENOVATION
OF THE DAYCARE FACILITIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE DEMENTIA RELATED MEMORY
DISORDERS. AS OTHER SENIORS WHO
REQUIRE CARE AND SUPERVISION.
I DURING THE DAY AS WELL
FOLLOWING THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
RECESSION CALIFORNIANS HAVE
SUFFERED DO THAT CLOSURE OF
DOZENS OF HOMES AND COMMUNITY
ADULT DAY SERVICES. AS
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED TO SERVE
THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF PERSONS WITH
DEMENTIA AS WELL AS OUR FAMILY
CAREGIVERS IN ADDITION MORE THAN
ONE HUNDRED ADULT DAY HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES. HAVE CLOSED AT
THE SAME TIME THAT CALIFORNIA'S
PROJECTED SENIOR POPULATION IS
GROWING AT A SIGNIFICANT RATE.
THESE COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES
FOR THE ELDERLY HAVE BEEN
REDUCED IN MANY CASES THE COST
FOR NONPROFIT OPEN MODERNIZE OUR
CONTINUE THE OPERATION OF THESE
DAYCARE PROGRAMS FOR THE ELDERLY
IS PROHIBITIVE. THE COST OF
START UP CONSTRUCTION RENOVATION
OR EQUIPMENT REPLACEMENT
CONSTITUTES THE PRIMARY BARRIER
TO CONTINUING OR EXPANDING THESE
VALUABLE SERVICES. THIS MEASURE
WILL HELP TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THE GROWING SENIOR POPULATION
WITH SPECIAL EMPHASIS ON THE
FRAIL ELDERLY TO ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS TO REMAIN IN THEIR
HOMES LONGER. PRESERVE THEIR
DIGNITY AND QUALITY OF LIFE
WHILE ALSO AVOIDING
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE COSTLY
INSTITUTIONALIZATION
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE A PAT MARTIN
AND DON MYERS PERKY.
AND ALSO I SHOULD ADD AT SUSAN
DEY. MARAH. I'VE MAIENSCHEIN SI
PROJECTS FOR ME. LAST DAM.
WITH ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION
AND LYDIA.
PLEASE MISCELLANEOUS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR ADULT
DAY SERVICES WHO ARE CO SPONSORS
OF AB TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND
WOULD BE HERE FOR ANY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
THANK YOU. PLEASE OKAY GREAT ALL
MY NAME IS PAT MARTIN THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR INTRODUCING THIS
BILL AND THANK YOU. TO THIS
ENTIRE COMMITTEE FOR LISTENING
TO ME I WAS GOING TO YOU ABOUT
MY PERSONAL STORY BECAUSE I
THINK IT TELLS IT TELLS Y. THIS
BILL IS SO IMPORTANT AND WHY WE
NEED THIS TO HAPPEN.
MIGHT MY DAUGHTER SAID FOR HER
ONE OF THE WORST DAYS OF HER
LIFE WAS WHEN HER FATHER SET THE
TABLE WITH THREE FORKS AND
SPOONS.
ONE I.
AND SHE WAS SHE WAS FOURTEEN
YEARS OLD. AND SHE SAID YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHAT I KNEW SOMETHING WAS
REALLY REALLY WRONG WITH DAD.
AND BILL HAD STARTED SHOWING
SOME COGNITIVE ISSUES BUT HE
WAS.
ACTIVE IN HIS CAREER STRESSFUL
JOB.
MAYBE THAT'S WHAT WAS GOING ON
WELL THAT WASN'T WHAT WAS GOING
ON. OF BILL WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
DEMENTIA.
AND.
HE HAD TO LEAVE HIS JOB.
IT WAS A WAS A GOOD.
IN OJAI EARNED EARNING JOB. I
ALSO HAD A VERY ACTIVE CAREER
WITH THE CLOROX COMPANY AND I
HAD TO LEAVE MY JOB TO TAKE CARE
OF BILL.
BILL WAS FIFTY FIVE I WAS FORTY
NINE.
SO MY CAREER ENDED AT AGE FORTY
WHEN WE WERE CONFRONTED WITH
THIS I LOOKED INTO THE OPTIONS
FOR ADULT DAYCARE. WE LIVED IN
FREMONT.
BIG CITY.
AND THERE WERE NO DEMENTIA
SPECIFIC FACILITIES.
OF FOR ADULT DAYCARE IN FREMONT
THERE WERE. DATE FACILITIES FOR
THE FRAIL AND ELDERLY THE BILL
WASN'T FRAIL WHEN HE WASN'T
ELDERLY HE WAS QUITE ACTIVE IN
EXCEPT FOR HIS COGNITIVE ISSUES.
HE WAS FINE.
SO I'VE QUIT MY JOB AND I
STARTING CARE OF HIM.
FOR ANY OF YOU WHO HAVE EVER.
EXPERIENCE IT'S EXHAUSTING. I.
NO NOT ONLY DO YOU NOT KNOW
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN MOMENT TO
MOMENT. YOU. THOUGHT YOU GET
ISOLATED YOU DON'T SEE PEOPLE
ANYMORE YOUR WORLD GETS SMALLER
AND SMALLER YOU DON'T SLEEP
BECAUSE IF. WE BUILD OUT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT I HAD TO DO
WITH THAT OR I WOULD JUST BE
WORRIED GO WAS GOING TO GET UP
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT NOT
WHO DO WITH THAT.
AND I DID MY BEST AND IT GOT
WORSE AND WORSE AND WORSE AND IT
WAS IT WAS BASICALLY TAKING ME
OUT.
AND THEN I FOUND THE ALZHEIMER'S
ACTIVITY CENTER IN SAN JOSE.
WHICH MISTER KALRA HAS VISITED
AYE AND THE ALSO WAS ACTIVITY
CENTER AYE IN THE HEART OF SAN
JOSE IS A DEMENTIA SPECIFIC
ADULT DAYCARE.
AND I WAS ABLE TO TAKE BILL
THERE. THEY HAD ACTIVITIES FOR
BILL THAT WERE APPROPRIATE PER
PERSON HIS AGE HE COULD PUT
BOCCE BALL HE COULD PLAY
SHUFFLEBOARD HE CAN RUN AROUND
THE BACKYARD. AND I KNEW HE WAS
IN A PLACE THAT WAS SAFE AND
TREATED WITH DIGNITY. AND I
COULD GO TO THE GYM WE'RE GOING
TO LUNCH WITH SCOTLAND FOR
SOMEBODY YOUR TAKE A NAP.
JUST HAVE A.
HAVE A BREAK.
SO I LIKE TO THINK THAT THE
ALZHEIMER'S ACTIVITY CENTER SAVE
MY LIFE.
IT REALLY DID. AND IN FACT NOW
I'M ON THE BOARD OF THE
ALZHEIMER'S ACTIVITY CENTER
BECAUSE YOU KNOW IT IT MEANS SO
MUCH TO ME.
BUT THEY ALSO WOULD LIKE TO BE
CENTER ITS GREATEST IDEAS AND
SITTING SAN JOSE.
IS THE ONLY DEMENTIA SPECIFIC
DAYCARE CENTER IN SAN JOSE. AND
SANTA CLARA COUNTY FOR THAT
MATTER.
IT'S OURS EIGHTY TO NINETY
PEOPLE THE DAY.
MORE THAN THIRTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
HAVE ALZHEIMER'S IN THE COUNTY
OF SANTA CLARA.
AND WE HAVE ONE FACILITY THAT
SERVES EIGHTY TO NINETY.
SO THIS TELLS US THE STORY IN
THIS IS A VERY POPULATED URBAN
AREA.
THERE WERE SIX OR THOUSAND
PEOPLE THAT HAVE THIS DISEASE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I KNOW.
THE SAME SITUATION EVERYWHERE.
SO. BE ON THE SORTS OF CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS THEY TAKE TIME TO
TAKE PLANNING.
SO I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY. I
DON'T THINK WE SHOULD BE WAITING
ANY ANY LONGER FOR THE SORT OF
INVESTMENT SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DONE MYERS
PERKY AND I'M THE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR AT YOLO ADULT DAY
HEALTH CENTER.
WHICH IS IN THE COUNTY NEXT
DOOR AND I'VE BEEN THE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR THERE FOR TWENTY TWO
YEARS AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. WHO ARE IN THE SAME
POSITION AS I AM TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO EXPAND OUR
PROGRAMS IN ORDER TO MEET THE
JOIN OR MISS NEED?
WE'VE BEEN ADVOCATING AND WE
ARE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE BECAUSE IT REALLY
TARGETS THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND IT IS IS
DESIGNED FOR NONPROFIT AND
GOVERNMENT. AND WHICH IS EXACTLY
WHAT I NEED NOW I TELL YOU A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT.
I COME TO YOU TODAY QUITE
DESPERATE TO BE QUITE HONEST AND
EXHAUSTED I'M EXHAUSTED FROM
SPENDING LAST YEAR FIVE YEARS OF
MY CAREER TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO EXPAND OUR PROGRAM IN
YOLO COUNTY. THERE'S NO CAPITAL
MONEY THERE'S NO REDEVELOPMENT
DOLLARS THERE'S REALLY NO WAY I
CAN GET OUT A LOAN TO DO IT
BECAUSE THEN I CAN'T AFFORD THE
MORTGAGE.
SO I RAN A GOOD CENTER IT'S A
MEDIUM SMALL QUITE HONESTLY IN
IN.
THE CENTER IS THIRTY FIVE YEARS
OLD. WE SERVE FIFTY NINE PEOPLE
A DAY WE HAVE EIGHTY ONE PEOPLE
IN ROLE. AND WITH EACH
PARTICIPANT WE SERVE COMES OF OF
FAMILY MEMBERS AND IN SOME CASES
WE ARE ALSO THE CLOSEST THING TO
FAMILIES.
WE ARE THE NEED IS GROWING AND
I'VE SEEN A STAGGERING.
GROWTH IN DEMAND IN MY TWENTY
TWO YEARS THERE AND WE HAVE A
VERY.
SAT WAITING LISTS THERE'S FIFTY
SEVEN PEOPLE ON THAT LIST AND
THE AVERAGE LENGTH OF TIME THAT
YOU ARE ON THAT LIST IS ALMOST
TWELVE MONTHS.
AND SO.
THAT.
HAS BEEN TRAXXAS TWO THOUSAND
AND FIFTEEN AND BY THE TIME WE
GET TO PEOPLE ON THAT LIST.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
TWENTY FOUR HAVE DIED ON THE
WAITING LIST AND FOURTEEN
REPLACED IN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES NOW WE'RE QUITE PROUD
OF OUR CENTER WAS THE FIRST BILL
TO PURPOSE ADULT DAY HEALTH
CENTER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR
WITH DOLLARS THAT WERE MADE MADE
AVAILABLE. AT THE TIME FOR
CENTERS TO BE BUILT.
AND WHILE IT WAS STATE OF THE
ART THE TIME YOU SHOULD SEE IT
NOW.
WE HAVE WE HAVE WORK THAT
BUILDING OVER I'M WE HAVE
TERRIBLE NINE ADA COMPLIANCE.
THAT WE'RE GRANDFATHERED IN
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
EXPAND FOR THE SIMPLE FACT THAT
IF WE DO WE HAVE TO SPEND ALMOST
A MILLION DOLLARS IN
RETROFITTING. WE DO NOT HAVE
SPRINKLER SYSTEMS WE HAVE TWO TO
THREE PEOPLE IN AN OFFICE OUR
DOORWAYS ARE ARE NOT WIDE ENOUGH
AND WE HAVE FOUR TOILETS FOR ALL
THOSE PEOPLE I JUST DESCRIBED
AND EIGHTEEN STAFF.
IT'S WELL KNOWN IN THE COUNTY
THAT WE NEED YOU TO IMPROVE AND
EXPAND OUR SPACE AND YOU WOULD
THINK OF THE LEADERS IN THE
COMMUNICATIVE FAULT WE GET THE
SOLUTION. BUT THAT HASN'T BEEN
THE CASE I'M WITH DIGNITY HEALTH
AND I'M ALSO WELL CONNECTED TO
THE COUNTY BECAUSE THE ON THE
LICENSE FOR A PROGRAM. THE
LEADERSHIPS OF BOTH THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE BEEN.
IN A TWO YEAR CONTRACT TO TRY
AND SOLVE THIS PROBLEM AND THEY
HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO DO SO AND
HAVE JUST RESIGNED A SECOND TWO
YEAR CONTRACT. HOPING THAT
PERHAPS WE CAN SAVE THE PROGRAM
WE LOSE CLOSE TO THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR AND
NOBODY CAN AFFORD TO COVER THAT
FOR US ANYMORE AND MET IN ITS
SIMPLY BECAUSE MEDICARE'S
REIMBURSEMENT RATE DOESN'T COVER
THE COST.
IF WE COULD EXPAND OUR PROGRAM
TO SERVE A HUNDRED PEOPLE A DAY
WE WOULD BREAK EVEN THAT'S ALL
WE'RE LOOKING FOR. AND THERE IS
SUCH A NEED OUT THERE BUT WHERE
IS THE CAPITAL COME FROM.
AND LIKE I SAID WE CAN'T AFFORD
A LARGE MORTGAGE THE HOSPITAL
CLINIC SYSTEMS AND COMMITTEE
PROVIDERS KEEP SENDING US
REFERRALS DISCHARGE PLANNERS IN
HOSPITAL SOCIAL WORKERS CALL ALL
THE TIME COULD YOU PLEASE BUMPS
OWN SO UP THE LIST. WE REALLY.
WITH VERY A VERY DESPERATE
SITUATION AND THE WAITING LIST
GROWS IF I WERE AWARDED TWO
MILLION DOLLARS.
OF THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
THAT'S ONE ONE THOUSANDTH.
OF WHAT MIGHT BE AVAILABLE TO
ALL PROVIDERS IN THE STATE I
COULD CHANGE THE COURSE OF LONG
TERM CARE COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES IN YOLO COUNTY AND
POSITIVELY IMPACT THE LIVES FOR
MANY MANY YEARS TO COME. THAT'S
JUST MY STORY AB TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE IS CAPABLE OF GROWING I
SPOTTED INFRASTRUCTURE INTO A
REAL SYSTEM OF CARE FOR
CALIFORNIANS A SYSTEM THAT SAVES
HEALTHCARE DOLLARS. PROMOTES
QUALITY OF LIFE CREATES JOBS HOW
MANY PEOPLE DO YOU KNOW TODAY
WHO ARE LOSING THEIR
INDEPENDENCE DUE TO CHRONIC
DISEASE OR AGE OR DEMENTIA I'M
GUESSING THE LIST IN YOUR HEAD
INCLUDES FAMILY MEMBERS FRIENDS
NEIGHBORS CO WORKERS. THAT'S WHO
WE'RE HERE TO SERVE IT'S ALL OF
US AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU THOUGH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF ANYONE ELSE HERE IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SUSAN MORRIS
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION AS A CO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORTER OF TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON LYDIA MISSILE
LEVI'S.
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
ADULT DAY SERVICES CO SPONSOR
AND HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
FRED MADE ON BEHALF OF CALPERS
THE PROGRAM FOR THE ALL
INCLUSIVE CARE. FOR THE ELDERLY
IN SUPPORT WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ON TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
TO MAKE THE BILL WORK THANK.
CAROL SUE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING THE
COMMISSION STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THIS EFFORT TO CREATE A STRONG
STRUCTURE OF SERVICES FOR THEM
DEMENTIA POPULATION THINKING.
LISA COLEMAN WITH CHALCO A
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION WE LOOK AT
THIS IS A WORK DETERRENT TO KEEP
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY LONGER.
AND OFF OF THE.
WELL.
GOOD BILL.
LAUREN RALPH CALIFORNIA SENIOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL SPIRIT NEEDED.
KAREN JONES LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN SERVICES OF SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY AND A COW CHO A
MEMBER AND WE SUPPORT THE BILL.
NIKKI LOWER LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM COORDINATOR
SANTA CRUZ AND SYMPHONY OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE OPPOSITION.
I ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY SO.
ANYTHING ELSE.
THE SAME EVER I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND
THAT WOULD RESPECT I REQUEST AND
I ABOUT.
THANK YOU.
MCGUIRE DOES HAVE AN AYE
RECOMMENDATION AND WE DO HAVE A
MOTION FOR SUMMARY GLORIA
SECONDED BY SUMMER CABALLERO
SIMPLISTIC WELL IN THE BOOK.
KALRA.
I KALRA AYE VOEPEL AYE. VOEPEL
AYE ALLEN. COVER YARROW. CAREER
I GIPSON. GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE RUBIO.
THE MEASURES OF.
BUT MEASURE PASSES WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR MEMBERS HAVE NOT
VOTED.
I SAW HIM IRWIN.
A. B..
TWENTY SEVEN NINE SEEM.
BOTTOM SIX.
WE BE BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY ALRIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF AGENTS
AGING ADMINISTERS PROGRAMS FOR
OUR STATE SENIOR POPULATION AND
PRIORITIZE A CERTAIN FUNDING FOR
INDIVIDUALS IDENTIFIED AS IN.
GREATEST SOCIAL OR ECONOMIC NEED
ALREADY PRIORITIZING THOSE WITH
LANGUAGE BARRIERS AND SOCIAL
ISOLATION CALIFORNIA'S MOST
RECENT STATE PLAN ON AGING SEEKS
TO BETTER SERVE MEMBERS OF OUR
LGBTQ COMMUNITY. HISTORICALLY
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMUNITY A FACE
MANY TYPES OF DISCRIMINATION
WHICH CAN CONTRIBUTE TO ECONOMIC
INSECURITY OR LACK OF ADEQUATE
HEALTH CARE.
WITHIN THE STATE'S ELDERLY
COMMUNITY LGBTQ INDIVIDUAL STILL
FACE VARIOUS FORMS OF
DISCRIMINATION THAT CAN LEAD TO
SOCIAL ISOLATION AND VARIOUS
OTHER HEALTH CHALLENGES. AS
CALIFORNIA MOVES FORWARD TOWARD
RECOGNIZING THESE THE UNIQUE
NEEDS OF LGBTQ SENIORS AB TWENTY
SEVEN NINETEEN CONTINUOUS EFFORT
BY ENSURING THAT THEY ARE
INCLUDED IN PRIORITIZE PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES. TODAY WITH ME HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT IS JOE MICHAEL
WITH THE QUALITY CALIFORNIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JOHN MICHAEL
FOR EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND
WE'RE PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR
OF THIS BILL ALONG WITH SAGE THE
NATIONAL ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
FOR LGBTQ OLDER ADULTS. SO I'M
GOING TO ATTEMPT TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF BOTH OF US TODAY
BRIEFLY. AND DATA AND RESEARCH
AND THE EXPERIENCE OF SAGE AND
ITS AFFILIATES AND EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AND AND I
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
CONFIRMED THAT LGBTQ OLDER
ADULTS FACE A NUMBER OF BARRIERS
TO SUCCESSFUL AGING. AND HIGHER
RATES OF SOCIAL ISOLATION THERE
TWICE AS LIKELY TO LIVE ALONE
AND HALF AS LIKELY TO HAVE CLOSE
RELATIVES TO CALL FOR HELP.
LGBTQ OLDER ADULTS ALSO FACE
HIGHER RATES OF POVERTY AND THAN
THEIR NON LGBTQ PEERS NEARLY
SIXTEEN PERCENT OF SINGLE GAY
MEN OVER SIXTY FIVE LIVE IN
POVERTY. COMPARED TO JUST NINE
POINT SEVEN PERCENT OF SINGLE
STRAIGHT MEN THEIR AGE.
SIX PERCENT OF LESBIAN COUPLES
AGE SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER HAVE
INCOMES BELOW THE POVERTY LINE
COMPARED TO THREE POINT FIVE
PERCENT OF MARRIED DIFFERENT SEX
COUPLES IN THE SAME AGE GROUP.
AND TO MAKE MATTERS WORSE LGBTQ
OLDER ADULTS ALSO FACE
PRONOUNCED HEALTH DISPARITIES.
SO DESPITE THESE NEEDS TO RELY
ON SERVICE PROVIDERS LGBTQ OLDER
ADULTS LACK CULTURALLY COMPETENT
CARE AND SERVICES. ON A STUDY
INDICATES THAT LGBTQ OLDER
ADULTS ARE TWENTY PERCENT LESS
LIKELY THAN OTHER OLDER ADULTS
TO ACCESS GOVERNMENT SERVICES
LIKE HOUSING ASSISTANCE MEAL
PROGRAMS FOOD STAMPS AND SENIOR
CENTERS. ALL THIS BACKGROUND
REALLY EMPHASIZES THE NEED FOR
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
AGING TO BE A LEADER IN
PROVIDING LGBTQ INCLUSIVE
SERVICES AND THIS BILL IS PART
OF BUILDING THAT LEADERSHIP SO
WHERE'S THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THE OTHER ONE THIS IS A SPORT.
ALRIGHT IS THERE.
ANYONE THE AUDIENCE LIKE SPEAK
IN SUPPORT.
HEATHER HARRISON WITH A
CALIFORNIA ASSISTED LIVING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MIKE MONTGOMERY CONGRESS OF
CALIFORNIA SENIORS WE SUPPORT
THE BILL.
RIGHT. AYE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
I IF NOT WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS OR.
IS THERE'S A SORRY PLEASE CAROL
SO CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
AGING IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
AND NO ONE OPPOSITIONS WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
ALRIGHT.
WE HAVE WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
TABLE.
NOW I WON A.
I THINK I'M ASSEMBLY IRWIN FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
I LEARNED A LOT.
JUST MY ROLE HERE OVER THE LAST.
LITTLE OVER A YEAR AND AND ONE
OF THE THINGS I HAVE LEARNED IS
THAT.
I DON'T THINK.
WE DON'T END UP IDENTIFIED THE
ISSUES ARE UNIQUE TO LGBTQ
SENIORS AND ARE NOT JUST THE
ISOLATION OF THE ABUSE THAT THEY
PACES WHILE INCLUDING. OTHER
RISK HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE OF
THAT ISOLATION ABUSE SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THE
BY THE THIS BILLBOARD AND YOU ME
CLOSE.
SPECTRALLY ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AND SO WE DO HAVE A AND I
RECOMMENDTION.
AND WE HAVE A MOTION BY SUMMER
CABALLERO SECONDED BY GLORIA
PLEASE TAKE ALL.
KALRA AYE KALRA AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE ALLEN CABALLERO.
CAREER AYE GIPSON.
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE RUBIO.
ALRIGHT SO THAT MEASURE PASSES
AND WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
MEMBERS NOW BUT IT.
YOU VERY MUCH.
AND A SIGN OF LIMON.
AND THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE A. B.
NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE.
AND YOU MAY PROCEED WHENEVER YOU
IN YOUR WITNESS.
I THINK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AND. ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE IS THE
THIRD LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH IN
CALIFORNIA AND ONLY IN THE ONLY
DISEASE IN THE TOP TEN CAUSES OF
DEATH WITHOUT APPROVING BECAUSE.
PREVENTIVE ACTION OR CURE IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY SIX HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS ARE
LIVING WITH THE DISEASE.
FOR ME AND FOR MANY OTHER
CALIFORNIANS THIS IS A DEEPLY
PERSONAL ISSUE AS MY OWN
GRANDMOTHER HAS. A TRAVEL
THROUGH THE ALZHEIMER'S SPACE
HAND MY FAMILY HAS FACED THE
STRUGGLE OF DEMENTIA CARE.
AB NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE PROMOTES
COMMUNITY EDUCATION AND PUBLIC
AWARENESS OF THE SYMPTOMS OF
ALZHEIMER'S AND PROVIDES
INFORMATION AND RESOURCES FOR
INDIVIDUAL. FAMILIES MEMBER FOR
INDIVIDUALS FAMILY MEMBERS AND
CAREGIVERS AFFECTED BY
ALZHEIMER'S AND RELATED
DEMENTIAS.
AB NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE WOULD
IMPLEMENT A PUBLIC AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN TO REDUCE STIGMA AND
RAISE PUBLIC AWARENESS. OF THE
WARNING SIGNS OF ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE AND DEMENTIA IN ORDER TO
PROMOTE EARLY. DETECTION AND
ACCURATE DIAGNOSES.
EARLY DETECTION AND DIAGNOSIS IS
A CRITICAL STEP TOWARDS
IMPROVING HEALTH OUTCOMES
LORRAINE HEALTHCARE COSTS AND
ENSURING ACCESS TO BENEFICIAL
INTERVENTIONS TODAY WITH ME I
HAVE DEREK HELT XIN JOHN LUCAS
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOHN
LUCAS.
I'M A VOLUNTEER ADVOCATE FOR THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION. MY WIFE
AND I.
MOVED UP HERE FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO THE SILICON VALLEY
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX.
AFTER I GRADUATED FROM UC SANTA
BARBARA RIGHT I MIGHT BE S. W.
DEGREE AND I GOT A JOB IN.
THEY A SEMICONDUCTOR BUSINESS
IN SANTA CLARA.
I HAVE THIRTY FOUR YEARS CAREER
IN THE TECH INDUSTRY IN
ENGINEERING AND ENGINEERING
MANAGEMENT.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY IN TO TELL YOU ABOUT
HOW THIS ISSUE HAS AFFECTED ME
AND MY FAMILY.
MY WIFE SHARON.
WAS DIAGNOSED WITH YOUNG ONSET
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE IN TWENTY
TEN AT THE AGE OF FIFTY SIX.
IT TOOK EIGHT MONTHS.
MANY STRESSFUL TRIPS TO THE
DOCTORS AND LABS.
A CT SCAN.
A PET SCAN.
AND FINALLY AN INVASIVE LUMBAR
TAP TO DRAW SPINAL FLUID FROM
HER TO GET THE DIAGNOSIS.
WE FINALLY GOT THAT DIAGNOSIS I
WAS COMPLETELY UNTRAINED.
AS TO WHAT I WAS GOING TO HAVE
TO DO OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS.
AND TWENTY FOUR HOUR PERIOD
AFTER GIVING THE DIAGNOSIS I HAD
TO MAKE A DECISION ON WHAT I WAS
GOING TO DO WITH MY CAREER.
I DECIDED TO RETIRE.
MUCH EARLIER THAN I EVER PLAN.
I HAVE NO TIME TO PREPARE.
AS A DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS OF A
MAJOR SEMICONDUCTOR COMPANY I
LEFT MY ENTIRE ORGANIZATION AND
MY BOSS THE VP OF THAT
ORGANIZATION IN A LURCH.
AND NO ONE TO DO MY JOB.
I TOOK CARE SHARON HOME TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN FOR A LITTLE OVER TWO
YEARS.
I FINALLY BURNED OUT WAS ON THE
VERGE OF DEPRESSION AND DIDN'T
THINK I WAS GONNA MAKE.
SO I PLACER AND THE BEST A
DEMENTIA RESIDENTIAL CARE IN
JANUARY OF TWO THOUSAND AND
THIRTEEN.
STILL THERE TODAY OVER FIVE
YEARS LATER CONTINUING TO DIE
WITH THE DISEASE.
SHE CAN NO LONGER SPEAK.
SHE DOESN'T KNOW WHO ANYONE IS.
SHE'S INCONTINENT.
JUST ENGAGED AND NEED SOMEONE
ELSE TO PERFORM ALL ACTS OF
DAILY LIFE FOR.
AT THE TIME OF HER DIAGNOSIS THE
NEUROLOGIST ONE OF STANFORD'S
BEST AND TODAY THE HEAD OF THEIR
ALZHEIMER'S UNIT.
ALL THIS ONLY ADVICE TO ME WAS
CALL THE ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION
I GOT NO OTHER INFORMATION FROM
THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY AT THAT
POINT.
I'M A PRETTY SMART GUY.
I KIND OF KNOW HOW THINGS WORK
IN THIS WORLD.
I HAD LOTS OF RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO ME IN THAT IN THE A
IN THE SANTA CLARA VALLEY.
BUT YOU YET EVEN WITH ALL THAT.
I DO KNOW WHAT TO DO.
I CAN'T IMAGINE HOW DIFFICULT
THIS IS.
OR PEOPLE AND LESS FORTUNATE
SITUATIONS IN MY.
HAD WE HAD AWAY FOR EARLY
DETECTION BACK THEN.
THE DISEASE.
A FOR THE DISEASE THINGS WHAT
ABOUT A LOT WHOLE LOT BETTER IN
A WHOLE LOT EASIER FOR MY MYSELF
AND MY FAMILY.
WE COULD PUT A FINANCIAL PLAN
TOGETHER FOR ONE THING.
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE IS THE MOST
EXPENSIVE DISEASE IN AMERICA.
IT'S GONNA COST THE COUNTRY OVER
A QUARTER TRILLION DOLLARS THIS
YEAR ALONE.
PERSONALLY I'VE SPENT OVER FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
OUT OF POCKET FOR HER CARE IN
THE U. S. USE IN THE RESIDENTIAL
FACILITY.
I COULD A PLAN THE TRANSITION
FROM MY JOB.
CRITICS IN MONTHS OR YEARS TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET OUT OF MY
POSITION LET SOMEBODY ELSE TAKE
OVER.
WE COULD LEARN ABOUT THE CARE
THAT SHE WAS GOING TO NEED.
I COULD I PUT A PLAN IN PLACE
FOR THAT WE HAD NONE.
BECAUSE BEEN A LOT MORE TIME
TOGETHER AS A FAMILY HAD WE
KNOWN THIS WAS GOING TO HAPPEN
YEARS IN ADVANCE.
ESPECIALLY. OUR TIME BETWEEN HER
DAUGHTERS AND HER.
WE CAN ACROSS THINGS OFFER
BUCKET LIST BEFORE SHE WAS TOO
SICK TO ENJOY AND APPRECIATE
THEM.
IN CONCLUSION I'D LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN THE MALL.
FOR BRINGING THIS UP AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING TO HELP
OTHER FAMILIES AVOID THE IMMENSE
HURDLES I'VE HAD TO FACE.
EARLY DETECTION AND PUBLIC
AWARENESS OR KEY.
AND SUPPLYING HELP FOR THE OTHER
PEOPLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR.
YES MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
DEREK HELT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING.
A I ALSO WISH TO THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LIMON FOR HER AND
LEADERSHIP.
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
SEE FOR A IS PROUD TO BE PART OF
AB NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE.
THE BILL DOES PROVIDE OUR REACH
TO OVER TWO MILLION CALIFORNIANS
THAT ARE BEING IMPACTED BY THIS.
HER DISEASE
WITH ACCURATE INFORMATION
HELPFUL GUIDANCE
AND LOCAL REFERRALS IN THEIR
TIME OF GREATEST NEED.
EARLY DETECTION AND INFORMATION
DOES MATTER.
YET THERE IS NO SYSTEMATIC
APPROACH.
TO EDUCATING THE PUBLIC ABOUT
AVAILABLE RESOURCES
AB NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE WILL
RESOLVE THAT. WILL START THE
PROCESS EARLY.
EARLY ON WHEN INTERVENTION IS
MOST HELPFUL FOR THE PATIENT AND
FAMILY.
AB NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE CREATES
AN ALLIANCE.
BETWEEN THE ALZHEIMER'S
ORGANIZATIONS AND AREA AGENCIES
ON AGING.
A PARTNERSHIP.
THAT TAKES ADVANTAGE OF WHAT
BEST BOTH BRING. TO TO THAT
ALLIANCE.
THE ALLIANCE WILL BUILD ON LOCAL
CAPACITY TO PROMOTE EARLY
DETECTION DIAGNOSIS OF
ALZHEIMER'S THE SEAS.
THROUGH AN EVIDENCE INFORMED
COMMUNITY BASED PUBLIC OUTREACH
INITIALLY.
THE ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION IS
WELL REGARDED.
FOR THEIR EXPERIENCE EXPERTISE
AND COMMITMENT TO EMPOWER
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR FAMILY TO
ADDRESS CARE NEEDS.
MEANWHILE.
PUBLIC INFORMATION ASSISTANT HIS
A CORE ELEMENT. OF AREA AGENCIES
ON AGING.
A SERVICE THAT IS MANDATED BY
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW.
WE ARE EXCITED TO WEAR KEEP BE
ABLE TO WORK WITH THE
ALZHEIMER'S CALIFORNIA.
ON AB NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE. AND
FORGING A WELL THOUGHT OUT
PROGRAM THAT WILL BENEFIT
ALZHEIMER'S PATIENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOES ANYONE
ELSE HERE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SUSAN TO MORRIS
ON BEHALF OF THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION WE ARE A SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL WE URGE OUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
I'M DOCTOR RUN SIMPSON
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY FOR
THE ELDERLY OPERATOR IN SUPPORT.
FRED MAIN CAL PACE IN SUPPORT.
HEATHER HARRISON CALIFORNIA
ASSISTED LIVING ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
PAR AND RALPH CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE I MEAN SUPPORT.
MIKE MONTGOMERY CONGRESS OF
CALIFORNIA SENIORS WE SUPPORT
THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MONICA
MILLER REPRESENTING ALZHEIMER'S
GREATER LOS ANGELES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
CAROL SOON THEY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING
IN SUPPORT.
JEAN HEARSE HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS AND ALSO
THE COUNTY OF VENTURA AND
SUPPORT.
LISA COLEMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
I'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SO WHEN I FIRST SAW THIS ON
THINKING ALRIGHT WHY DO WE NEED
THIS BUT RESEARCH SHOWS ME.
THAT.
THIS WAS THAT THE.
PLANT MASTER PLAN TO COMBAT
ALZHEIMER'S WAS PASSED IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN.
IT.
THE PLANNED NEVER SHOWED UP INTO
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN. AND THEN
NOTHING HAPPENED.
AND THERE'S BEEN QUITE A BIT OF
MONEY.
THAT FINANCES THIS BUT NOTHING
HAPPENED.
SO TO THE AUTHOR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON. THIS IS A
BRILLIANT BILL.
I'M.
YOU KNOW.
I THINK IT'S WONDERFUL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
BUT IT AND.
.
I AGREE I THINK IT'S A GREAT
BILL I AND I THINK THAT.
THEN I DON'T THINK IT'S
COINCIDENCE THAT THIS YEAR WE'RE
SEEING NUMBER OF BILLS.
RELATED HOUSE HIGHWAYS
ALZHEIMER'S CARE ALZHEIMER'S
RESEARCH ALZHEIMER'S AS A KID
EDUCATION. OF MY AND I GIVE
GREAT CREDIT TO ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE.
LIKE SEE FOR A LIKE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION SO MANY ADVOCATES
THAT ARE HERE ARE THE MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY TO THE FAMILY
MEMBERS THAT ARE STEPPING
FORWARD TO SPEAKING UP.
YOU HAVE ENOUGH ON YOUR PLATE
FOR YOU TO TAKE THE TIME TO
ADVOCATE. AYE IS INCREDIBLY
COURAGEOUS AND VERY COMMENDABLE
SOMEONE A THANK YOU.
AND MOST QUICKLY AS AN EARLY
MON.
YOU KNOW WITHOUT YOU CARRY IN
THE BILL.
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT IT LEAVES
A BIG GAP IN WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
IN TERMS COMBATING ALZHEIMER'S
AND SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
YOU CAN'T CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THIS DOES
HAPPEN AYE RECOMMENDATION AYE
AND WE HAVE A MOTION FROM THE
SUMMER CABALLERO SECOND FROM
SUMMER GLORIA OF PLEASE TAKE
WELL.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I.
ALAN.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO AYE GIPSON.
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE.
ALRIGHT WITH THAT MEASURE PASSES
WILL HOLD ALL OPEN FOR ANY
MEMBERS HAVE NOT VOTED THANK
YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES YES I YES
I.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVEN A. B.
TWO SEVEN FOUR FOUR SO WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. AND YOUR WITNESS
ALREADY MAY.
PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
AB TWO SEVEN FOUR FOUR PROVIDES
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AROUND THE
ACTIVITIES OF REFERRAL AGENCIES
FOR FAMILIES LOOKING TO PLACE
PRIMARILY DISABLED AND ELDERLY
FAMILY MEMBERS. INTO LONG TERM
RESIDENTIAL CARE.
THIS BILL WILL ASSURE THAT
CONSUMERS HAVE CLEAR TRANSPARENT
INFORMATION ABOUT THE REFERRAL
PROCESS.
FINDING QUALITY HOUSING AND CARE
FOR A LOVED ONE.
CAN BE DAUNTING. EVEN THAT UNDER
THE MOST IDEAL CIRCUMSTANCES.
FOR MOST THIS DECISION CAN FEEL
RUSHED CREATING AN ENVIRONMENT
THAT MAKES FAMILIES AND SENIORS.
MORE SUSCEPTIBLE TO PRESSURE AND
MISINFORMATION.
UNFORTUNATELY THE CONSUMER OFTEN
DOES NOT HAVE THE TIME RESOURCES
OR EXPERTISE TO MAKE THE MOST
INFORMED DECISION FOR THEMSELVES
OR THEIR LOVED ONES. ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT COMES TO ELDER CARE
PLACEMENT AND HOUSING OPTIONS.
IT IS AT THIS JUNCTURE THE
REFERRAL AGENCIES CAN BE OF
GREAT HELP.
OR GREATER HARM TO CALIFORNIANS.
REFERRAL AGENCIES OFFER SENIORS
AND FAMILIES ASSISTANCE IN
FINDING PLACEMENT IN A CARE
FACILITY. USUALLY A LICENSED
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY FOR
THE ELDERLY.
THESE ARE OFTEN FREE OF CHARGE
TO THE PERSON BEING REFERRED.
THESE REFERRAL AGENCIES ARE
LARGELY UNREGULATED IN
CALIFORNIA AND FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES THEY RECEIVE. ARE NOT
ALWAYS CLEARLY DISCLOSED TO THE
SENIOR BEING PLACED OR THEIR
FAMILIES.
REFERRAL AGENCIES ALSO ARE NOT
ALWAYS NECESSARILY FAMILIAR WITH
THE FACILITIES TO WHICH THEY'RE
REFERRING SENIORS OR EVEN THE
SPECIFIC NEEDS OF THE SENIOR
THEY ARE REFERRING.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THESE ISSUES
AND PROVIDES THE NEEDED
TRANSPARENCY AND PROTECTION.
HERE TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THE
BILL IS LINDA ARE MOST.
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL REFERRAL
EMPLACEMENT ALLIANCE AND RONALD
SIMPSON DIRECTOR AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PRESIDENT OF SIXPENCE
INK. ALONG WITH THE ROCKS AND
GOULD FROM GOLD GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS WHO WILL COME UP TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
ESPECIALLY.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RADIUS FOR
AUTHORING SUCH AN IMPORTANT
BELL.
WHEN AN ELDERLY PERSON MAKES
WHAT'S OFTEN THE LAST TO MOVE
THAT THEIR LIFE. IT'S RARELY A
JOYFUL HAPPY OCCASION IT USUALLY
INVOLVES COMPLICATION.
COMPLICATED EMOTIONS STRESS
CONFUSION AND GUILT.
AND THAT USUALLY WITH FORTY
EIGHT HOURS OR LESS NOTICE.
PREVIOUSLY THIS PROFESSION HAS
BEEN COMPLETELY UNREGULATED WITH
NO CONSUMER PROTECTIONS OUR
MINIMUM STANDARDS. MANY PEOPLE
ARE NOT EVEN AWARE OF THE
VALUABLE SERVICE.
THAT SENIOR REFERRAL AGENCIES
CAN PROVIDE UNTIL THERE'S A NEED
TO FIND CARE FOR AN ELDERLY
FAMILY MEMBER USUALLY IN A
CRISIS.
THEN THERE IS NO TIME TO SHOP
AROUND.
FOR HELP THE THE PUBLIC MAKES
REASONABLE ASSUMPTIONS WHEN THEY
READ PROMISES ABOUT EXPERT
ADVISORS THAT WILL HOLD THEIR
HAND THROUGH EVERY STEP OF THE
PROCESS.
TO HELP THEM FIND PLACES
TAILORED TO THEIR UNIQUE NEEDS.
THEY DON'T THINK TO QUESTION
WHETHER THAT SENIOR HOUSING
ADVISER SLASH EXPERT HAS EVER
EVEN SEEN OUR KNOWS ANYTHING
ABOUT THE PLACES THEY ARE
RECOMMENDING. IT SHOULDN'T
MATTER WHERE WHETHER A FAMILY IS
SEARCHING ONLINE OR USING A
LOCAL REFERRAL AGENCY.
CONSUMER EXPECT EXPECTATIONS AND
NEEDS ARE THE SAME AND THE
STATE'S SAME STANDARD SHOULD
APPLY.
TRAINING AND EXPERIENCE DO
MATTER. THERE'S A CONDITION
CALLED RELOCATION STRESS
SYNDROME OR TRANSFER TRAUMA
WHICH CAN CAUSE CRITICAL
EMOTIONAL. AND BEHAVIORAL
SYMPTOMS ESPECIALLY AND FRAIL OR
CONFUSED ELDERLY.
SEARCHING FOR APPROPRIATE
HOUSING AND CARE IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN SHOPPING FOR
APPAREL SHOES ARE AN OUTFIT THAT
CAN BE RETURNED IF IT'S NOT A
GOOD FIT.
A PLACE THAT'S PERFECT FOR ONE
MAY BE COMPLETELY WRONG OR EVEN
DANGEROUS FOR ANOTHER.
FAMILY SHOULD HAVE A RIGHT TO
HONEST DISCLOSURE THAT THE
AGENCY WILL BE PAID A
COMMISSION.
AND THE RIGHT TO CANCEL AND WORK
WITH ANOTHER AGENCY IF NOT
SATISFIED WITH THE SERVICE THEY
RECEIVE.
THERE ARE MULTITUDES OF
INNOCUOUS LOOKING WEBSITES
POSING AS INFORMATIONAL SITES.
THAT MEAN WE SERVE TO CAPTURE
CONTACT INFORMATION.
THAT CAN BE SOLD OR USED TO
REFER PEOPLE TO ASSISTED LIVING
PASS THE FACILITIES FOR A
COMMISSION.
OFTEN THE FAMILY HAS NO
KNOWLEDGE THIS HAS HAPPENED
UNTIL THEIR PHONE STARTS
RINGING.
THE COMPANY CAN ALSO CLAIM TO
REPRESENT THAT CLIENT
INDEFINITELY WITHOUT THEIR
PERMISSION. EVEN AFTER BEING
TOLD DECEASED CONTACT AND AY
STILL COLLECT COMMISSIONS YEARS
LATER. BECAUSE OF TERMS THAT ARE
BURIED IN THE FINE PRINT OF
PRIVACY POLICY.
TEXAS THE WHICH NOBODY EVER
READ.
BECAUSE THEY NEVER ACTUALLY
OPTED IN THERE IS NO WAY FOR
FAMILIES TO OPT OUT FAMILIES
DESERVE CHOICES AND
TRANSPARENCY.
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY FOUR IS
ABOUT PROTECTING SENIORS AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
NAVIGATING THIS COMPLICATED
PROCESS OF FINDING AN
APPROPRIATE CARE FACILITY.
FAMILIES IN NEED OF THIS SERVICE
ARE USUALLY IN CRISIS.
IT IS ALSO A DIFFICULT EMOTIONAL
TIME OVER FIFTY PERCENT OF
THOSE.
SEEKING HELP FEEL GUILTY ABOUT
MAKING THIS PLACEMENT.
CONSEQUENTLY THEY ARE EVEN MORE
VULNERABLE OFTEN UNAWARE WHEN
THEY GO ON THE INTERNET SEEKING
INFORMATION THEY ARE AGREEING TO
ALLOW THE REFERRAL AGENCY TO
DISCLOSE AND EVEN SELL OUR
PERSONAL INFORMATION.
MORE TRANSPARENCY IS NEEDED IN
THIS AREA AND THIS BILL WILL
CODIFY THAT REQUIREMENT.
JUST A WEEK AGO I MET WITH A
GENTLEMAN LOOKING TO PLACE HIS
MOTHER.
HE TOLD ME. THAT DAYS BEFORE HE
WENT ON THE INTERNET SEEKING
INFORMATION ANY HARDLY FINISHED
WHEN HE HUNG UP THE PHONE AND
WINNIE FINISHED AND GOT OFF THE
INTERNET HIS PHONE STARTED
RINGING NONSTOP.
PEOPLE SEEKING HELP
FROM REFERRAL AGENTS EXPECT
INDIVIDUALS REPRESENTING
THEMSELVES AS EXPERTS TO
UNDERSTAND BASIC CARE
REQUIREMENTS FOR SUCH THINGS AS
COGNITIVE LOSS DIABETES
CONGESTIVE HEART FAILURE.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE NO TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS
ANYONE.
ANYONE CAN SAY THAT THEY ARE AN
EXPERT REFERRAL AGENT.
WE NEED TO CHANGE THIS AND
ESTABLISH MINIMAL TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS SO FAMILIES ARE
REASSURED THAT REFERRAL AGENTS
CAN EVALUATE AND MAKE
APPROPRIATE PLACEMENTS.
THERE IS GRAFT AND COLLUSION IN
THIS INDUSTRY THAT INFLUENCES
THE WAY CLIENTS ARE ACQUIRED AND
REFERRALS ARE MADE.
THIS RESULTS IN REFERRALS MADE
FREQUENTLY FOR FINANCIAL GAIN
NOT FOR THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
NEEDY SENIOR.
THE IS PERVASIVE INDUSTRY
KICKBACKS CONTINUE EVEN THOUGH
THEY ARE UNETHICAL IF NOT
ILLEGAL.
THIS CREATES UNFAIR BUSINESS
PRACTICES AND EVEN WORSE AN
INCENTIVE FOR PLACEMENT AND
FACILITIES THAT ARE NOT
APPROPRIATE.
THIS BILL OPENS TO PRACTICAL
SIGNIFICANT MEANS OF ENFORCEMENT
ONE. ACTION IN SMALL CLAIMS
COURT.
TO REMOVAL FROM THE REGISTRY BY
DSS MAKING IT ILLEGAL TO PROVIDE
A REFERRAL.
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE. I AM WORRIED
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT.
BILL TO PROVIDE PROTECTIONS
NEEDED FOR OUR SENIOR ADULTS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AYE ANYONE
ELSE'S SUPPORT.
YOU'RE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROXY AND
WILL REPRESENTING SIX BEDS DOT
ORG WORD ASSOCIATION WAS FORMED
FOUR YEARS AGO.
SIX BEDS ARE FEWER RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY
SMALL FAMILY TYPE SETTINGS AND
WE JUST WANT TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR FOR THIS MUCH NEEDED
LEGISLATION.
HEATHER HARRISON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSISTED LIVING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
GEN HAMPTON WITH LEADING EDGE
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING A FOUR
HUNDRED PROVIDERS OF NOT FOR
PROFIT SENIOR FOR A HOUSING.
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY IN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AT THE STATE AND
STRONG SUPPORT THINKING.
RACHEL TATE WISE ON THE HEALTHY
AGING LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN
SUPPORT.
HI AM HURRY SECAM A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER OF ON OUR CFE AND
SIXPENCE MEMBER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS CYNTHIA MARINAS
NUMBER OF SIX BAD AND I AM AN
ICF <c.green> ADMINISTRATOR
AND</c>
OWNER AND I'M IN SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME'S NOTI SEKI AB YOU
KNOW PUTTING CARE HOME FOR
TWENTY FOUR YEARS A SUPPORT HIS.
YEAH.
I CAN REALLY GEIST'S FROM NAPA
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AGNES MOOREHEAD ELDORADO
HILLS
CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
BILL I'M AN RCMP OWNER AND AS
WELL AS ADMINISTRATOR.
CAROL SUL FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING IN SUPPORT.
LAUREN RALPH SENIOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SUSAN TO MORRIS ON BEHALF OF THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
NIKKI LOWER OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM
FENNICA SAN BENITO COUNTY IF I
AM IN THE FIELD AND WHEN I HEAR
OF THESE AGENCIES ITS ALMOST
RECKLESS THE WAY THEY'RE
OPERATING AGREEMENT STRONG
SUPPORT.
KAREN JONES LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN SERVICES OF SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY AND ALSO A CO CO A
MEMBER. ALSO VERY STRONG AND
SUPPORT I HAVE. MANY MANY YEARS
TWENTY YEARS IN THE PROGRAM AND
MANY STORIES ABOUT GOOD AND BAD
BUT AN AWFUL LOT ABOUT WITH
THESE. PROVIDERS AND THANK YOU
FOR THE BILL.
LISA COLEMAN CALIFORNIA LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CASEY SOCCER HARA CEO OF THE
SENIOR CONNECTION WE ARE
REFERRAL AGENCY I AM IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS AS ICY
MISPLACEMENT HAPPEN ALL THE
TIME.
THE GIFTING.
IT'S HORRIBLE I'M VERY MUCH IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
RUSKIN NANCY FROM ORANGE COUNTY
MY WIFE LIVE IN BUSINESS TWENTY
TWO YEARS OPERATING YEAH THREE
RESIDENTIAL CARE HOMES. AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT HIS BILL TO
BRING SOME FAIR BUSINESS
PRACTICES IN HIS INTO INDUSTRY.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MONICA
MILLER REPRESENTING ALL TIMES
GREATER LOS ANGELES AND
ALZHEIMER'S ORANGE COUNTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MIKE MONTGOMERY CONGRESS OF
CALIFORNIA SENIORS WITH THE
BILL.
THANK YOU WELL ANYONE. ELSE'S
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I ALSO OWN A.
CARE FACILITY. AND I'M IN
SUPPORT WITH THIS BILL OKAY
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT
IF NOT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS.
I PATRICK SHANNON AND I
REPRESENT CARING DOT COM WITH
THE LARGEST CALIFORNIA BASED
REFERRAL AGENCY.
AND WE ARE AN INFORMATION
SERVICES COMPANY OPERATING ON AN
INTERNET MODEL.
AND WE HELP FAMILIES IDENTIFY
SENIOR HOUSING OPTIONS THROUGH
RATINGS REVIEWS VIDEO AND ADVICE
FROM OUR FAMILY ADVISERS.
ALL FREE TO THE CONSUMER.
THAT WE SUPPORT CONCEPTS IN THE
BILL SUCH IS DISCLOSURE OF THE
FOLLOWING.
WHETHER THE FACILITY COMPENSATES
THE REFERRAL AGENCY.
IT'S GOOD.
DISCLOSURE A PRIVACY POLICY THE
INFORMATION SHARING POLICY AND
THE TELEPHONE CALLING POLICY.
PLUS THE INSURANCE COVERAGE
REQUIREMENTS THE BAN ON THE
POWER OF ATTORNEY.
NOW WHILE WE SUPPORT CONSUMER
PROTECTION IN THE INDUSTRY AND
INDEED PRACTICE IT OURSELVES WE
OPPOSE THE BILL AS OVER BROUGHT
IN OTHER RESPECTS AND IN FACT
DISCRIMINATORY AGAINST THE
INTERNET BUSINESS MODEL.
A LESS EGREGIOUS VERSION OF THIS
BILL AN SP SIX FORTY EIGHT WAS
ALREADY VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN. AS TOO
EXPANSIVE AND UNNECESSARY.
HE SAID THE PROPONENTS HAD
FAILED TO PRODUCE A CONVINCING
CASE FOR THE NEED FOR THE BILL.
OVER THE REGULATION IN CURRENT
LAW.
S. B. SIX FORTY EIGHT ALSO
PREVIOUSLY FAILED NOT ONCE BUT
TWICE IN THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AGAIN
AS UNNECESSARY.
NOW NOTE THAT OVER THE LAST
THREE YEARS THE PROPONENTS HAVE
PRODUCED NO ACTUAL EVIDENCE OF
ANY PROBLEM TO BE RECTIFIED.
NO STUDIES.
NO SURVEY OF COMPLAINTS AGAINST
REFERRAL AGENCIES NO EVIDENCE OF
ANY REGULATORY OR DA ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS.
WE CANNOT LEGISLATE BY INNUENDO.
PROPONENTS OF PRODUCED NO
INDICATE EVIDENCE INDICATE THAT
THE EXISTING THREE TIERED
REGULATORY SYSTEM IN PLACE FOR
THE LAST TWENTY SEVEN YEARS AND
REGULATED BY DSS IS NOT WORKING.
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE SECTION
FIFTEEN SIXTY NINE POINT FORTY
SEVEN PUNISHES AS A MISDEMEANOR
ANY INAPPROPRIATE REFERRAL TO AN
UNLICENSED FACILITY OR THE WRONG
LEVEL OF CARE.
FACILITIES ARE REQUIRED BY
STATUTE.
TO CONDUCT A RIGOROUS
SUITABILITY DETERMINATION BEFORE
ADMITTING A RESIDENT.
AND DSS POLICES THE REFERRAL
AGENCIES AND THE FACILITY FOR
VIOLATIONS.
NOW OF CONSUMER PROTECTION IS
THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL WHY ARE
SEVENTY PERCENT OF ALL REFERRALS
EXEMPT FROM THIS BILL.
ALL OF THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL SHOULD APPLY TO ALL
REFERRAL SOURCES EQUALLY
INCLUDING SELF REFERRALS BY
FIFTY PERCENT WHICH REPRESENT
FIFTY PERCENT OF ALL REFERRALS.
AND SO CALLED PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES
PROVIDERS LIKE LAWYERS AND
DOCTORS IN THE STATE PLANNERS
WHO REPRESENT TWENTY PERCENT OF
THE REFERRALS.
THE BILL ONLY REGULATES BUSINESS
REFERRAL AGENCIES AND THAT'S
ONLY THIRTY PERCENT.
BUT THIS BILL ADDS EVEN MORE
REGULATION OVER BUSINESS
REFERRALS.
AGENCIES UNIQUELY AN EXCLUSIVELY
AND VEERS FAR OFF COURSE INTO A
TURF WAR SEEKING TO LEGISLATE
ECONOMIC ADVANTAGES FOR THE
LOCAL AGENCIES.
THE SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL OVER
THE INTERNET AGENCIES AND FOR
THE FACILITIES OVER THE REFERRAL
AGENCIES.
THIS MAY HELP EXPLAIN WHY THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION THE SPONSOR
OF S. B. SIX FORTY EIGHT IS NOT.
SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
I CAN LIST SOME OF THESE
PROVISIONS THAT THE BILL SEEKS
TO SUPER WIEN AND NEGOTIATED
CONTRACTS
BETWEEN THEIR FOR ALL AGENCIES
IN THE FACILITIES. AND REPLACE
THEM WITH LEGISLATIVE LEAD.
DICTATED PROVISIONS THAT SKEW
THE ECONOMICS OF THE
RELATIONSHIP.
IF YOU WILL LET ME GO FOR MAYBE
ANOTHER MINUTE I CAN GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF WHERE THE
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES LAW. OF
ALL THAT YOU USE THAT AS YOUR
CLOTHES SUCH ELECTED CHAU
ANECDOTES TO THAT OKAY. YET WELL
IMAGES AND IT DOES SO THE LOCAL
AGENCY OF SOUGHT TO ELIMINATE A
CORE PRINCIPLE CALLED THE FIRST
IN CONTRACT PROVISION WHICH
REFERRAL AGENCIES USE
NATIONWIDE.
AND INSTEAD OF LEAVING THE
DECISION OF HOW AGENCIES ARE
COMPENSATED TO NEGOTIATIONS THE
BILL BASICALLY TRIES TO AVOID
THE FIRST IN PROVISION.
SIMILARLY THE LOCAL AGENCIES
HAVE SOUGHT A ONE AND DONE RULE
WHERE REFERRAL AGENTS DON'T GET
CREDIT FOR SUBSEQUENT REFERRALS
IF THERE'S A MOVE OUT AGAIN
THAT'S THE SUBJECT OF
NEGOTIATION BETWEEN FACILITIES
AND REFERRAL AGENCIES. IT'S NOT
THE IDEA TO REPLACE NEGOTIATION
WITH A LEGISLATION.
SO IN CLOSING WHAT I'D SAY IS I
WANT TO BE CLEAR. OUT WE ALL
LIKE SOME PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
BUT THOSE THAT ARE
DISCRIMINATORY OR BURDENSOME WE
OPPOSE THE PARTICULARLY THOSE
THAT TEND TO SKEW THE ECONOMIC
RELATIONSHIP TO BENEFIT. THE
LOCAL AGENCIES OVER THE INTERNET
AGENCIES AND I'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE TO
IDENTIFY AND EXTRACT THOSE
PROVISIONS.
WELL THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN CLIPPER HERE IN
BEHALF OF A PLACE FOR MOM OF THE
NATION'S PROBABLY LEADING AND
LARGEST INTERNET UP REFERRAL
AGENCY.
WE SUPPORTED S. B. SIX FORTY
EIGHT.
SENATOR MENDOZA IS BILL THAT
WAS SUPPORTED BY CONSUMER
FEDERATION. THAT WAS FOCUSED
PRIMARILY ON CONSUMER
PROTECTION%
AND CONSUMER DISCLOSURES WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THOSE PROVISIONS
IN THIS BILL.
WHEN THE BILL WAS FIRST
INTRODUCED.
AND HEARD IN HUMAN SERVICES ó
WE WERE OPPOSE. INITIALLY
BECAUSE OF A NUMBER OF
PROVISIONS THAT SOUGHT TO
REGULATE THE BUSINESS TO
BUSINESS RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
FACILITIES AND REFERRAL
AGENCIES.
WHICH ARE THE SUBJECT OF
CONTRACTS IN OUR BB
RELATIONSHIPS.
ARE WE WORK WITH THE AUTHOR IN
THE U. MEANT SERVICES COMMITTEE
TO RESOLVE MOST OF THOSE ISSUES
WE ONLY HAVE ONE MORE ISSUE
INSIGNIFICANT ISSUE LEFT WITH
THE BILL WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ON THAT. AND WE HOPE TO
RESOLVE THAT AND BE ABLE TO LEVY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE DO
SUPPORT. TRANSPARENCY
CONSUMER CONSUMER DISCLOSURE BUT
WE DON'T THINK THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD GET INVOLVED IN BUSINESS
TO BUSINESS RELATIONSHIPS
THERE'S SUBJECT OF CONTRACT AND.
THE FEES THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
THOSE BIZARRE RELATIONSHIPS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY I WILL BRING A BACK UP TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS
QUESTIONS.
YES SOME OUR COPIER.
YES ACTUALLY IF YOU COULD
ADDRESSED KIND OF THE LAST
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE M. IN
TERMS OF YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL IT WOULD BE HELPFUL JUST TO
KNOW WHAT WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ARE
IN TERMS OF THE.
TIM THE CONCERNS WITH THE
ELECTRONIC FOR ALL SYSTEM AND
THAT BUSINESS TO BUSINESS
CONTRACT RELATIONSHIP.
I'M NOT SINGLE REPRESENTING SIX
BEDS UP OUR INTEREST.
HAS ACTUALLY NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE BUSINESS MODEL HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH AN INTERNET MODEL
IT'S REALLY. AN INTERESTING
TRANSPARENCY AND DISCLOSURE AND
I'M ON MY EXPERIENCE WAS THAT I
WAS TRYING TO FIND A PLACE FOR
MY MOM.
I'M IN REPRESENTS EXPENSE I HAD
THE BENEFIT OF HAVING AN ACTUAL
NAME OF FACILITY I DID A GOOGLE
SEARCH I ENDED UP GOING THROUGH
SIX PAGES OF DIFFERENT
FACILITIES WITH PICTURES
APPEARING TO BE THE HOME I WAS
LOOKING FOR. AND EACH TIME I
CALLED IT WAS REFERRAL AGENCY
AND WAS NO DISCLOSURE THAT
THAT'S WHAT IT WAS IT WASN'T
UNTIL I GOT TO THE ALZHEIMER'S
PAGE. THAT ACTUALLY FOUND THE
HOME I WAS LOOKING FOR SO WHAT
IT IS REALLY ABOUT IS MAKING
SURE THAT IT IS IT IS REFERRAL
AGENCY. THEY ARTICULATE THAT
THAT IS CLEARLY DISCLOSED THAT
IF THERE IS IN FACT A FEE BEING
PAID UNLIKE MANY OF THE ADS THAT
SAY IT'S FREE THAT'S WEEKLY
DISCLOSED. AND THAT THEY SHOULD
HAVE A FAMILIARITY WITH THE
RESIDENTS CONDITION AND THE HOME
THEY'RE TRYING TO PLACE THEM IN
AND SO THE ONLINE MODEL IF THEY
CAN MEET THOSE CONDITIONS WE
HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH THAT
WHATSOEVER.
AND AND I'M.
THEY HIT OF THE SUMMER AS. NO
OTHER.
YES BUT.
SO.
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU THAT
YOU YOU WITH CARING DOT COM
RIGHT.
RIGHT AND THEIR REPRESENTATIVES
CORRECT ALRIGHT. IN OPPOSITION.
CORRECT
YOUR ONLINE FOR FREE CORRECT.
CORRECT TO THE CONSUMER.
HOW DO YOU MAKE YOUR MONEY?
WELL WE DISCLOSE THAT ON OUR
PAGE OF COURSE WE MAKE MONEY A
NUMBER OF WAYS.
ONE WAY WE DO MAKE MONEY IS WE
DO GET A. SO CALLED COMMISSION
FROM THE FACILITIES AND WE
DISCLOSE THAT ALREADY IS WHO WE
DO AGREE WITH THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
THAT SHOULD BE DISCLOSED.
SO YES INDEED WE IN FACT THAT'S
HOW THE AGENCY WORKS THERE
EITHER PAID BASED ON.
THE PERCENTAGE OF FIRST MONTH'S
RENT OR THEY'RE PAID FOR
QUALIFIED LEADS
JUST LIKE ANY OTHER CONTRACT
MARKETING AGENCY OPERATES THE
SAME MODEL.
SO IF YOU DON'T MAKE A PLACEMENT
DOES THE.
FACILITY REFUND THAT.
FREE.
WELL IT DEPENDS ON WHAT THE FEE
ARRANGEMENT AS ITS SUBJECT
BETWEEN NEGOTIATIONS OF THE
FACILITY AND THE REFERRAL AGENCY
BUT IF THE MODEL IS A PAYMENT
FOR A MOVIN AND OF COURSE ONLY
IF THERE'S A MOVING DO YOU GET
PAID. IF IT'S A PAYMENT FOR
QUALIFIED LEAD YOU COULD GET
PAID FOR QUALIFIED LATE.
IT'S SUBJECT TO NEGOTIATION AND
SHOULD NOT BE DICTATED BY
LEGISLATION.
UNDER APART FROM THE DISCLOSURE
THE DISCLOSURES FINE.
BUT THE QUESTION IS CAN YOU
DICTATE WHAT THE ECONOMICS ARE
OF THE UNDERLYING TRANSACTION
THAT'S A BRIDGE TOO FAR.
THANK YOU SIR.
I HAVE TWO MORE QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR.
MONNING NOW WERE DONE. YEAH.
BY SO OF MAY I OF THE.
ABSOLUTELY ARTHUR.
MY NEIGHBOR.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL CASE SO
THESE ARE CLARIFYING QUESTIONS
FOR ME AS YOU KNOW I HAVE AN
INQUIRING MIND I CAN HELP MY.
SO.
THIS AUTHORIZES DDS TO LEVY
CIVIL PENALTIES ON REFERRAL
AGENCIES PURSUANT TO CURRENT LAW
REGARDING CIVIL PENALTIES.
HOME HOW MUCH COULD THE.
.
THE. THE CIVIL PENALTY BE AND
HOW WOULD YOU APPLY IT TO
SOMEONE IT'S ONLINE.
THAT'S MY QUESTION.
IF I MAY HAVE OUR EXPERT RESPOND
TO THAT.
TWENTY ONE AND ONE.
FOR THOSE HOUSES CIVIL FEE
DETERMINED AND HOW DO YOU APPLY
IT TO.
.
AND AN ONLINE SERVICE SO
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY. HAVE CONTRACTS THEY
SIGN WITH REFERRAL AGENCIES AND
IT ESTABLISHES THAT THE FEE
WHICH IS. TYPICALLY. SOME
PERCENTAGE OF THE FIRST MONTH'S
RENT. AND IT GOES AS HIGH AS A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE PERCENT.
I'M SOME REFER ALLEGIANCE.
WE'LL LET YOU KNOW THAT IF YOU
HAPPEN TO GIVE THEM TWO HUNDRED
PERCENT MAYBE THEY'RE MORE
LIKELY TO SEND THAT REFERRAL TO
YOU'D AND SOMEBODY ELSE.
WHICH IS A REAL PROBLEM AND IT
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH FINDING
THE RIGHT HOUSE FOR THE ELDERLY.
SO ARE AND. AND THERE WAS
SOMETHING SAID ABOUT FIRST JAN
FIRST IN JUST MEANS SOMEBODY WHO
RUSHED OUT TO SEND OUT THE NAME
OF THIS PERSON AND THE CONTACT
INFORMATION FOR THE PERSON. IT
DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH
THE QUALITY OF SERVICE OR THE
VALUE ADDED IT'S GIVEN.
AND OFTENTIMES REFERRAL AGENTS
WHO ARE IN THE COMMUNITY. ARE
SPEND. DAYS AND WEEKS AND
SOMETIMES MONTHS WORKING WITH
PEOPLE TAKING THEM TO SEE HOMES
WITH NO IDEA IT'S SOMEONE ONLINE
HAD SENT IN. THE NAME OF THIS
PERSON TO THE HOUSE WHERE THEY
MAY END UP GOING AND THEN THAT
AGENCY SHOWS UP SINGLE YOU
UNLESS THE FEE RECENT AT FIRST.
AND.
IT DO YOU KNOW HOW MUCH THE
PENALTIES MAY BE.
HAS THAT BEEN ESTABLISH A NO NO
I'M IN AND THERE WAS SOMETHING
REFERRED TO A A LAW THAT MAKES.
IT IT ILLEGAL FOR REFER
ALLEGIANCE TO. TO DO SOMETHING
I'M NOT SURE WHAT IT IS THAT
THEY'RE ILLEGAL. BUT THIS IS
NEVER GOING TO RISE HIGH ENOUGH
ON A D. A SWISS THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT
AND THAT'S WHY THERE'S NEVER
BEEN ANY. ANYTHING REALLY
REPORTED THE GRAFT IN THE
INDUSTRY ISN'T RISING HIGH
ENOUGH FOR DE A TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT AND THIS BILL. MAKES
CODIFIES REQUIREMENTS THAT WILL
MAKE IT A PROBLEM AND AND FIND
WAYS THAT IT CAN BE ENFORCED.
SO DO YOU KNOW WHO AND WHEN
CIVIL PENALTIES WILL BE
ESTABLISHED.
YEAH I'M. I'M I.
THAT. THERE ARE THERE ARE NO
CIVIL PENALTIES ESTABLISHED IN
THIS BILL.
BOB BUT IT THERE WAS A THERE
WAS.
ARM. THEY THE PENALTY IS THAT.
THERE ARE REFERRAL AGENT IS
REMOVED FROM THE REGISTRY AND
THEN IT. MAKES IT ILLEGAL FOR
THEM.
TO MAKE A REFERRAL NOW YOU'RE
ASKING ME WHAT'S THE PENALTY OR
IF IT'S ILLEGAL TO MAKE A
REFERRAL AND AND. I'M ASSUMING
THAT WILL BE ESTABLISHED IN THE
FUTURE IS AT A SAFE ASSUMPTION.
THE BIGGEST THE BIGGEST PROBLEM
IS CAN. HAVING THOSE REFERRAL
AGENCIES ONCE THAT'S BEEN FOUND
THAT THEIR BEHAVIOR.
.
IT IS WRONG. TO THE AT TO HAVE
THEM TAKEN OFF THE REGISTRY SO
THEY CAN NO LONGER RECOVER A
FEED.
WHICH IS WHAT HOW THEY MAKE
THEIR THEIR BUSINESS ON THE
INTENSIVE CURRENT LAW ARE THERE
ALREADY IS A SMALL TOWN
ESTABLISHING CURRENT LAW TO THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR DETERMINING HOW THEY GO
ABOUT ESTABLISHING A FOR THIS
PARTICULAR PROTOCOL. SO SO
PENALTIES ALREADY EXIST A IN
TERMS OF LICENSING VIOLATIONS
AND AND THAT WOULD ALSO. THEN BE
EXTENDED FOR THE MORTAR REFERRAL
AGENCIES AND THAT WOULD BE OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO THIS BILL. FOR
THE DEPARTMENT TO COME UP WITH
THE STANDARD.
NOW GET NUMBERS TO PROTECT.
ZERO.
THAT WAS ONE QUESTION BAYSIDE.
THIS NUMBER TO KNOW.
SO.
YOU. DID A STEP WHICH IS WITHIN
THE STATE TREASURY OF
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY
REFERRAL AGENCY FUND. INTO WHICH
ALL FEES.
THE MONEY'S DE.
YOU DON'T WILL BE DEPOSITED.
HOW DOES THAT WORK?
BECAUSE ONCE AGAIN I'M ALWAYS
CONCERNED ABOUT IF IT WERE
PUNISHING SOMEONE AND WHERE THE
MONEY GOES I THINK ASSEMBLYMAN
AREIAS GAVE YOU THE ANSWER OF
THE PUNISHMENT IF THEY'RE TAKEN
OFF. THE REGISTRY THEN THEY
CANNOT BE COMPENSATED FOR MAKING
A REFERRAL.
AND SO THE HOMES LIKE MINE
KNOWING THAT THEY'RE OFF THE
REGISTRY DOESN'T DO WON'T HAVE
TO MAKE A PAYMENT. AND IF THEY
COME AFTER US THEIR SMALL CLAIMS
COURT WILL SETTLE THAT.
I GOT IT NOW OKAY THIS LOSER FEE
RIGHT.
THAT THAT DELUSION THREE RIGHT
WITH THAT THAT'S THE PENALTY
WHAT'S RIGHT NEAR A PARKING
TICKET.
IT IS LOSE YOUR FEELINGS OF IT
BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT AT A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY PERCENT. OF
A.
OF A FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR A
MONTH FEE IS SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
RIGHT AND SO THAT IT THAT IS NOT
INSIGNIFICANT.
YOU. CAN SOLVE THE THERE'S AN
AYE RECOMMENDATION.
THAT I'VE PUT FORWARD AS CHAIR
OF A THREE WRITTEN SPECIFICALLY
REASONS ONE IS I DO BELIEVE THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT PERSONAL
PROTECTION BUT AS NECESSARY.
SECONDLY.
IT WAS JUST THIS MATTER THIS
BILL WAS JUST HEARD.
AND HUMAN SERVICES LAST WEEKEND
OF THE CHAIR HUMAN SERVICES HERE
WITH US AMHERST AFTER A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK ON A
NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS. TO DEAL
WITH OPPOSITION NOW NOT ALL OF
OPPOSITIONS CONCERNS WERE NESTLE
MEMBER THINK MOST OF THEM WERE
MET BUT THEY'RE STILL MORE WORK
TO DO. AND THE THIRD REASON WHY
RECOMMENDED I.
IS AT THE CHAIR ARE THE SAME
MEMBERS COMMITTED TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH OPPOSITION ON THOSE
SPECIFIC ISSUES OBVIOUSLY GIVEN
THE FACT THAT TURN AROUND TIME.
FROM HUMAN SERVICES SO SHORT AND
THERE IS SO MUCH WORK DONE AT
HUMAN SERVICES I THINK IT'S
REASONABLE FOR US TO ALLOW THE
OPPORTUNITY. IDEA HOW TO HAVE A
SUMMARY AS TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH OPPOSITION ON THE REMAINING
ISSUES THAT UP THAT HUMAN
SERVICES AND IN SOME AREAS WERE
NOT ABLE TO. OF RECTIFY IT AND
YOU KNOW I IN LAST WEEK'S
MEETING BUT I THINK A LOT OF
WORK WAS DONE I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE. THAT YOU'RE RUBIO AT
HER STAFF AS WELL THE SONORA
REYES FOR THE WORK THAT HAS BEEN
DONE. AND I THINK OF THAT SHOWS
TO ME THE COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS AYE TO ENSURE
THAT THE CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
THAT EVERYONE SEEMS TO AGREE ARE
IMPORTANT INCLUDING OPPOSITION.
BUT ON SOME OF THOSE REMAINING
POINTS I THINK THERE'S STILL AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE FORWARD IN
OUR COLLABORATION AND SO WITH
THAT I DO RECOMMENDED I.
AND SO IT THERE'S.
A MOTION IP HAPPENED
ENTERTAINMENT CRYING AT THE
QUESTIONS THAT MEMBERS HAVE.
ALRIGHT AND SO WE HAVE A MOTION
OF NO FURTHER COMMENT LAST FOR
IS. PRESENT REYES LIKE CLOSE.
AB TWO SEVEN FOUR FOUR.
REALLY TAKES THE FIRST STEP
TOWARDS TRANSPARENCY.
AND TODAY I AM.
A QUESTION AND I VOTE SO WE CAN
MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS.
THANK YOU AND SO WE DO HAVE A
MOTION OF BY SENATOR RUBIO
SECONDED BY SOME A MEMBER
CABALLERO PLEASE TAKE WILL.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE ALLEN CABALLERO.
CAREER AYE GIPSON. GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO.
RUBIO I THINK YEAH.
ARE AYE.
ALRIGHT SO THAT ILL PASSES AND
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
THOSE OF MY TO VOTE THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHTS.
.
BUT NEXT WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU.
AND WE HAVE TWO ITEMS THAT IS SO
MUCH OF OUR DOING FILE ITEM. BUT
WE HAVE FILE ITEM ORDERS SO ITEM
FOR TWO ONE FIVE NINE . B..
TWO ONE FIVE NINE.
S. A RICHER WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
BUT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRS HAVE
MEMBERS.
AT. THIS BILL AB TWO ONE FIVE
NINE A. IS IS BLIZZARD APPROACH
TO PROTECT SENIORS FROM FALLING
VICTIMS
TWO FINANCIAL FRAUD TO BY
REQUIRING THEM. OF MONEY
TRANSMITTERS TO REPORT SUSPECTED
ACTIVITY TO LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
AN ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
AGENCY.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRED TO
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS LIKE A
BANK.
TO ACT AS A MANDATE THAT
REPORTERS
HA HA OF EVER DID THE MONEY
TRANSMITTERS ON NOT REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION. RELATED TO
FRAUD TARGETING SENIORS.
BODY OF A FILLING THIS CABIN LOG
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY NINE I. HAVE
A LAYER OF PROTECTION FOR SENIOR
DURING DO OKAY SHOWS INCLUDES
BUSINESS TRANSACTIONS ONG
CONDUCTED THROUGH MONEY WIRING
SERVICES.
SENIOR WILL A LOST MORE THAN
THIRTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR TO ELDER ABUSE.
FINANCIAL FOR ALL OF US ALONE.
ACCOUNT FOR ABOUT THIRTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN DO UNITED
STATES SENATE SPECIAL COMMITTEE
ON AGING RELATED. ON AN AGING
RELEASED OF COMPREHENSIVE REPORT
IDENTIFYING THE TOP TEN SENIOR
SCAMS
WHICH RANGE FROM COMPUTERS AND.
ALONE CONFIDENCE FRAUD AND
IDENTITY AND. IDENTITY THREAT.
WATER TRANSFER WAS CITED AS.
COMMONLY USED TOOL FOR
VICTIMIZED SO THE SENIORS.
WAS CALLED A POIGNANT SENIOR
POPULATION SET TO INCREASE BY
FOUR MEN IN SPITE YOUR TWENTIES
THIRTY.
IT IS IMPERATIVE TO TAKE
LEGISLATIVE ACTION TO PROTECT
THOSE GROWING SEGMENT IN THE
STATE.
BEFORE I CLOSE I WANT TO KNOW
THAT MY STUFF.
HOUSE WILL WORK WITH A
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
ON CLARIFYING RING I'M AMENDED
AMENDMENTS.
SHOULD THIS BILL WILL GIVE ALL
OF TO IS COMMITTED TODAY I WOULD
TAKE THOSE AMENDMENTS AND
JUDICIARY COMMITTEES.
I ALSO INTEND TO CLARIFY. THAT
THIS BILL WOULD BE MUCH BETTER
THAT IS WOULD BE MONEY
TRANSMITTERS.
AND NOT TO EMPLOYEES SCEPTER TO
CIVIL PENALTIES UNDER THIS BILL.
WITH ME TODAY.
IS.
WELL LAURIN RULES SENIOR AS HAVE
A. SENIOR ASSEMBLY MEMBERS HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
OFFERING THIS BILL.
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE
SUPPORTS THIS BILL IN TWO
THOUSAND AND ELEVEN WE WERE THIS
THE INITIAL OUR SPONSORS.
OF A BILL TO REQUIRE A EMPLOYEES
OF MONEY. WIRE TRANSFER
COMPANIES TO BE TRAINED.
TO BE A ABOUT THE DANGERS OUT OF
ELDER ABUSE AND THAT THE SCIENCE
A.
WHETHER SOMEONE IS ELDER ABUSE
AND YET FRAUD AND WIRE TRANSFER
LOSS OF MONIES JUST CONTINUES TO
GROW. AND THERE WAS A REPORT.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. THAT IN
LESS THAN SIX MONTHS. THE MONEY
TRANSFERRED IN OF LOS
THROUGH SCAMS.
WAS.
INCREASED FROM THREE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS TO FIVE POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS AND THAT'S
JUST IN LESS THAN SIX MONTHS.
SO CLEARLY JUST TRAINING THE
EMPLOYEES.
TO RECOGNIZE
OF THE ISSUE IS NOT SOLVING THE
PROBLEM. AND.
WITH NO THAT THANKS ARE THANK
EMPLOYEES ARE REQUIRED. MANDATED
REPORTERS AND IT HAS HELPED TO
SAVE.
HOW MANY THAT YOU KNOW MANY
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF MONEY?
?
THESE DAYS END OF INFORMATION ON
INDIVIDUALS IS AMAZINGLY
AVAILABLE IT IT'S.
IT'S INCREDIBLE I WAS AMAZED
WHEN. I HAS BEEN LOOKED ME UP
AND. HAD EVERYTHING ON ME
INCLUDING MY MY SALARY AND
EXACTLY HOW MUCH MONEY I MADE.
.
AND.
IT DOESN'T TAKE ITS NOT TO.
.
HARD
TO GET.
HOPE BY THE SCAMMERS I HAVE A
COUPLE OF STORIES I'D LIKE TO
TELL YOU.
MUSIC FRIENDS OF MINE.
A ONE IS A. VERY ASTUTE BUSINESS
WOMAN.
SHE HAS A OUR SENIOR RELATED
MAGAZINE.
AND SO SHE HAS A LOT OF
SUBSCRIBERS TO OUR MAGAZINE. HER
EMAIL FOR THE MAGAZINE GOT
HACKED AND IT SET OUT TO. ALL OF
THE SUBSCRIBERS OF THE MAGAZINE
A MESSAGE THAT SHE WAS STUCK IN
MANILA AND NEEDED SOME MONEY TO
BE ABLE TO GET. OUT.
SO THIS.
THIS MESSAGE WENT OUT TO ALL OF
THE SYSTEMS
DESCRIBERS NOW THIS IS A SENIOR
RELATED MAGAZINE IT'S FOR
SENIORS ABOUT SENIORS.
AND.
TWO OF THOSE SUBSCRIBERS EVEN
THOUGH THERE ARE THOUSANDS.
DID SEE AND MONEY.
THINKING THAT MY FRIEND TRACY
WAS IN TROUBLE.
AND IT WAS REALLY ASHAMED THEY
COULDN'T GET THAT MONEY BACK.
I HAVE ANOTHER FRIEND WHO'S WHO
HAS BEEN IN HER LIFE TIME.
HIGH EXECUTIVE IN THE UNITED
STATES POST OFFICE.
TRAVELED ALL OVER. THE UNITED
STATES AND THE WORLD A ON BEHALF
OF THE UNITED STATES POST OFFICE
RECENTLY SHE'S BEEN ILL WITH
CANCER.
AND AND SHE CONTINUES TO HAVE
ILLNESS.
.
WE SAY IN CONTACT WITH HER AND
TRIED TO HELP HER. SHE GOT A
PHONE CALL I MEAN THIS IS A
WOMAN WHO'S QUITE EDUCATED WHO'S
PRETTY SMART ABOUT BUSINESS
PRETTY SMART ABOUT HER MONEY.
SHE GOT A PHONE CALL.
.
FROM THE IRS I MEAN.
AND TELLING HER THAT SHE OWED A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF MONEY AND IF
SHE DIDN'T THAN THEY WERE GOING
TO SEND THE POLICE AFTER HER.
WELL BECAUSE OF HER ILLNESS AND
HER WEAKNESS.
SHE.
SHE JUST DIDN'T EVEN THINK THIS
IS A SCAM.
SO SHE WENT AND WIRE TRANSFERRED
HA. MONEY.
TO THIS THIS.
AND SHE DID I'M.
THEY WANTED IT SOME THROUGH
WALMART AND SOME THROUGH TARGET.
WELL WALMART TO ITS CREDIT.
REFUNDED HER MONEY.
VOLUNTARILY. UP BUT SHE WAS
STILL OUT QUITE A BIT OF MONEY
OF THESE.
IT'S JUST AN EXAMPLE OF IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE.
ELDERLY REALLY ELDERLY PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT ABLE TO HANDLE THEIR
OWN FINANCES IT CAN BE SOMEBODY
WHO.
JUST AS WORRIED ABOUT WHETHER
YOU KNOW SHE'S TAKING CARE OF
BUSINESS.
AND DATA AND IT CAN BE SOMEBODY
WHO'S TRYING TO HELP SENIORS.
YOU KNOW AND THEY GET TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF.
SO I REALLY. LIKE TO STE
TO SEE THIS BILL.
STEP UP THE REQUIREMENTS
ON THE WIRE TRANSFER COMPANIES.
AND MAKE MANDATED REPORTERS
OF THEIR EMPLOYEES THINK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OR ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON TWENTY TICKET
TELLING BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM.
MIKE MONTGOMERY CONGRESS OF
CALIFORNIA SENIORS WE SUPPORT
THE BILL.
CAROL SO FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING FINANCIAL
ABUSE OF THE ELDERLY INDEPENDENT
ADULTS IS ONE OF THE FASTEST
GROWING CRIMES IT'S OF A BIG
ISSUE.
FOR THE COMMISSION ON AGING AND
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THIS EFFORT
TO EXPAND. VIGILANCE TO TRY AND
STOP THIS THINKING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AYE ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF MY
NAME'S BOB GARCIA I REPRESENT
THE MONEY TRANSMITTERS OTHER
TOOK OUR TRADE ASSOCIATIONS CALL
THE MONEY SERVICES ROUNDTABLE
WERE COMPRISED OF THE LARGER
MONEY TRANSMITTERS.
JUST TO GIVE THE COMMITTEE SOME
CONTACTS.
THE BATTERY INDUSTRY HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS.
ACCORDING TO A TWENTY FIFTEEN
WORLD BANK STUDY A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS WERE
TRANSMITTED MADE BY IMMIGRANTS
WORKING IN THE USA.
TWENTY THREE BILLION TO MEXICO
THIRTEEN POINT.
FOUR FIVE BILLION TO CHINA TIM
POINTED TO INDIA TEN POINT OF
TEN TEN BILLION TO THE
PHILIPPINES.
WHY DO WE SEE THOSE KINDS OF
ARGUE?
WHICH I THINK INCREASE EVERY
YEAR ABOUT FOUR FIVE PERCENT.
OF. THIS IS BECAUSE
MONEY TRANSMISSION IS A
RELIABLE.
METHOD THAT IS THE ONLY METHOD
THAT MANY IMMIGRANTS TO THE
UNITED STATES CAN USE TO GET
NAM.
MONEY TO THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS
AND LOVED WHAT.
.
WE HAVE STRONG ANTI FRAUD
MEASURES IF YOU GO ON OUR WEB
PAGES THERE PROMINENTLY
FEATURED.
THE THE OTHER THING. OF AND I
SHOULD ADD THAT I REPRESENTED. A
AMERICAN EXPRESS WHEN THIS LAW
WAS ENACTED IN NINETEEN NINETY
HAVE BEEN WORKING OUT EVER
SINCE.
.
WE HAVE IT WAS ADDED TO THE LAWN
TWENTY ELEVEN A PROVISION THAT
ARE MY CLIENT COMPANIES WORK
WITH AGENTS TO EDUCATE THEM WE
DO THAT.
OF. OUR.
ó THE ALSO A.
ON THE RECEIPT FOR.
THERE IS UNNOTICED TOOK CALLED
THE DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS OF. A
OVERSIGHT IF THERE IS A
QUESTIONER UNEASE ABOUT A
TRANSMISSION.
I WANT TO FIVE OR SIX OF
LOCATIONS AROUND AROUND OF THE
CAPITAL AREA.
RIGHT EIGHT I WENT OVER THERE AT
LUNCH.
RIGHT NEXT TO THE WESTERN UNION
SIGN IS THE PLACARD TO CALL THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT
IT RIGHT THERE.
AND I THINK IT THEY'VE DONE A
GREAT JOB OF PUTTING THOSE
PLACARDS UP.
OF.
MY MAIN POINTS OF OPPOSITION I
HAVE TO BRING SOETHING OUT
BECAUSE I HAD A CONVERSATION
WITH A STAFF MEMBER. IT CAME UP
IN SOME IN CERTAIN CONVERSATIONS
AND I WAS REFERRING TO THE
LATINO COMMUNITY.
THAT THIS BILL COULD. DISRUPT OR
OR.
DIMINISHES THEIR WILLINGNESS TO
GO TO OF A JOB RETAIL OUTLET
LIKE RIGHT EIGHT.
IF THE WORD GETS OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO BE CARDING PEOPLE.
AND THAT'S A WHOLE DIFFERENT
DISCUSSION HOW DO YOU DIVINE THE
AGE OF A PERSON.
IF YOU'RE THAT RITE AID CLERK
ENOUGH TALK TO THE RETURNS
RETAILERS ARE TALK HOW DO YOU
FIGURE IT OUT.
IT'S HARD TO TELL HOW OLD
SOMEBODY IS BY THE WAY THEY
LOOK.
A AND THEN IT'S THE ONLY WAY YOU
DO THAT ISSUE CARD PEOPLE.
SO OF. THAT WAS NOT IN MY
POSITION LETTER BECAUSE IT CAME
UP IN A CONVERSATION BY SCALPERS
WHO ASKED IF I THOUGHT THAT WAS
A POSSIBILITY. I HAVE NO
CONCRETE EVIDENCE BUT I IT'S NOT
A BIG LEAP IN FAITH.
.
THE MAIN INTO OUTRIGHT A DEBRIEF
FEAR THAT. THE BILL IS FLAWED
BECAUSE IT MISUNDERSTANDS OUR
BUSINESS MODEL.
WE WORK THE COMPANY'S WORK WITH
A NETWORK OF AGENTS.
WE IT WERE HEAVILY REGULATED
THAT LIST OF AGENTS IS PROVIDED
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT. AND EVERY TIME A NEW
AGENT IS ADDED OF DESK INTERIOR
CONSIDERED MATERIAL CHANGE WE
HAVE TO NOTIFY DEAL BE WITH IN A
MONTH.
BUT.
SO WE HAVE NO. PHYSICAL
INTERACTION.
IN REAL TIME.
WITH A HUMAN BEING.
OUR AGENTS DO THAT.
THERE'S BEEN A GRAVITATION TWO
ONLINE TRANSMISSION THERE'S NO
INTERFACE THERE HOW CAN YOU TELL
IF THERE'S ELDER ABUSE GOING ON
WHEN IT'S IN ALL THE GOOD WE ARE
DOING ON THE COMPUTER.
THE OTHER THING AND I DO
RESPECT.
THE THE THE GROUPS ARE
SUPPORTING THE BILL.
BUT IT DOESN'T IT'S FLAWED IN
ITS UNDERSTANDING.
.
THE DATE OF ACTIONS THAT WERE
CITED IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
THE MOST RECENT ONE WAS TWENTY
TWELVE.
TWENTY TWELVE.
AND I I I. I ASKED THAT THE
PROPONENTS.
CAN THEY PRODUCE ONE COMPLAINT.
ONE COMPLAINT.
THAT.
ELDER ABUSE.
OCCURRED AT A RIGHT EIGHT.
OR A WESTERN WE'RE WATCHING
SERVICES ARE OR ANY OTHER
LOCATION.
THEY CAN'T PRODUCE ONE
COMPLAINT.
SO THE BILL TRIES TO FIX A
PROBLEM THAT DOESN'T EXIST.
IN BUYING PLACING OBLIGATIONS ON
OUR AGENT COMMUNITY. IT PUTS HIM
IN A HORRIBLE POSITION SO FOR
THOSE REASONS I OPPOSE THE BILL.
WE OPPOSED TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SOME OF THE GLORIA DID
YOU HAVE A.
OKAY BUT ANYONE ELSE OPPOSITION.
THAT THAT THAT AND THAT IS WHY
IN TERMS OF EQUITY IN TERMS OF
THE AMOUNT OF TIME WAS USED.
THAT THE PROPONENT WITNESS HAD
SO IF YOU JUST WANT TO DO A
QUICK A QUICK.
THIRTY SECONDS PERHAPS THEY
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MACHINE WILL NEED TO BE
HAVE TO CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION.
APPRECIATE MISTER CHIU BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I HAD HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH A HIS OFFICE
OF ASSUMING THE BILL MOVES HAPPY
TO CONTINUE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AND WORKING WITH THEM.
I'M HERE JUST QUICKLY ON BEHALF
OF WITHIN THE ASSOCIATIONS ARE
LARGE A GROCERY STORES.
CHAIN DRUGSTORES IT YOU MAY
KNOW THAT MAY COME TO MIND.
AND I'M HERE REALLY IN BEHALF
OF OUR AGENT COMMUNITY THAT
WOULD BE IMPLICATED IN THE BILL.
AND REALLY JUST AS WE THINK
THROUGH THIS THEIR LEVEL OF
DISCERNMENT GIVEN THEIR AGE
WHERE THEY'RE AT IN LIFE THE
TRANSIENT NATURE OF THE JOB.
THEIR ABILITY TO DISCERN.
WHAT'S GOING ON DURING THAT
TRANSACTION WHETHER OR NOT THAT
PERSON IS ACTUALLY UNDER ON IN
UNDUE INFLUENCE OR DURESS THE
BELIEVE* QUESTIONS MATURITY
LEVEL ALL THAT AND THEN TO HAVE
THE CORRESPONDING PUNISHMENT. IF
THEY DON'T AND THEY DON'T GET IT
RIGHT SO I'M I'M REALLY HERE TO
SPEAK TO THAT ISSUE SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE IT. I'M
ANYONE ELSE TO LEAD HIM UP THE
MIKE FROM HERE JUST A STATE
OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT LET'S BRING ABOUT
COMMITTEES ON A GLORIA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU FOR A THE
BILL IN THE PRESENTATION.
OBVIOUSLY ALL OF US ARE AGAINST
ELDER ABUSE.
YOU KNOW IF YOU WANT TO SCAN MY
GRANDMOTHER YOU BETTER LOOK OUT.
FOR YOU RIGHT.
SO I I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH IT'S ALWAYS
THE DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS I
THINK YOU SPOKE TO THIS A BIT
YOUR TESTIMONY. BUT MAYBE A
GLOVE QUESTION WHOSE CORAL
GETTING TO THE LAST SPEAKER.
THE IT SEEMS AS THOUGH THE
READING OF THIS BILL A WOULD.
MANDATE RETAIL WORKERS TO BE
MANDATED REPORTERS FOR ELDER
ABUSE IS THAT THE INTENT OF YOUR
BILL.
AND I JUST OF ANOTHER YOU KNOW
YOU ARE THE THE COMPANY.
WHAT THOUGH WENDY DETECTED
THERE'S A SUSPICIOUS OPEN?
OF FRAUDULENT.
AND REPORT IT TO DID THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT IT IN ANY EVENT
I COULD IF I COULD OF A SUMMER
SHE SO OF THE.
THE THE IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE ASSEMBLY CHIU WITHOUT WITH
OUR STAFF. ITS. THE AGENTS OR
THOSE THAT ARE THE AGENTS OF
THOSE THAT ARE.
PROVIDING THE SERVICE SO IF
THERE'S AN AGENT THAT HAPPENS TO
BE IF IT'S INMIGRANTE FOR YOU WE
SEE I'VE SEEN IT. THROUGHOUT MY
DISTRICT CERTAINLY ENGROSSING
STORIES YOU'LL SEE OP TIMES
THEIR WINDOWS WHAT HAVE YOU WELL
WHOEVER'S DOING THAT SERVICE WAS
NOT THAT NECESSARILY EVERYONE
THAT WORKS IN THAT GROCERY.
STORE EVERYONE THAT WORKS AS AN
EMPLOYEE OF THAT TO GO STROBE
THOUGH THOSE ARE ACTUALLY
PROVIDING THAT SERVICE ARE
WORKING AS AGENTS. OF THOSE
COMPANIES AND SO DAYS GO THERE
WOULD BE THE ONES THAT WOULD
FALL UNDER. MY UNDERSTANDING
CRACKING AROUND A LITTLE DIBELLA
ABOUT REQUIREMENTS.
SO IT READING THE. BILL IT'S I
THINK THERE MIGHT BE A LOT THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDED TO THAT TO
CLARIFY THAT BECAUSE MY
UNDERSTANDING. A LOT OF THESE
TRANSACTIONS CAN BE PERFORMED AT
THE MAIN REGISTERS.
AS IS MENTIONED EVEN ONLINE AND
YOU KNOW I. ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND
HOW BANKS CAN BE.
HELD ACCOUNTABLE YOU KNOW WHAT
I WOULD MAKE A CHARGE OUTSIDE OF
SAN DIEGO SACRAMENTO I GIVEN
NOTICE MY BANK RIGHT THEY CAN
MONITOR AND SEE THESE KINDS OF
TRANSACTIONS THEY HAVE SOME SORT
ALGORITHM OR IT PRODUCT THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO DO WHAT. I THINK
WHAT YOUR INTENT IS TO TRY IN
AND ALLOWS WITH WIRE TRANSFER
SERVICES STAFF SIMILAR
CAPABILITIES AND TO SORT
INTERVENE SOMEHOW AND THAT'S
DIFFERENT. BEEN EXPECTING A YOU
KNOW RELATIVELY YOUNG.
MINIMUM WAGE EMPLOYEE THAT MAY
HAVE NOT MINIMAL TRAINING IF ANY
TRAINING TO DO THIS WORK AND I.
WHEN THE WHEN THINKING ABOUT
THAT IN THE LIABILITY THAT WOULD
ACCRUE EITHER TO THEM BUT TO THE
EMPLOYER. AND FROM A LIMITED
TRANSACTION YOU KNOW OF A OF A
FEW SECONDS TIME BETTER
REGISTER.
I I WONDER IF THAT'S
AT A MINIMUM.
.
FALSE SENSE OF SECURITY OF FOR
IF THOSE WHO ADVOCATE FOR THIS
BILL.
OR AT A MINUTE OR OR CONVERSELY
ENOUGH SIGNIFICANT LIABILITY
WHEN THERE'S VERY LITTLE
EVIDENCE TO SUGGEST THAT SO I IS
THERE A WAY TO TIGHTEN THIS UP
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT NOT. YOU KNOW SOMEONE WHO
MAYBE SCOOPING ICE CREAM ONE
SECOND WORK IN THE REGISTER AND
SELLING GROCERIES THE NEXT AND
THEN ALSO WORKING THESE KINDS OF
TRANSACTIONS ARE WAY TO NARROW
THE SCOPE DOWN. GOVERNOR YOU
KNOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING THAT I THINK IS ALSO
VERY IMPORTANT.
A POINT YOU KNOW WE WE'RE TRYING
TO.
GO AFTER THOSE. WHO
SCAM YOU KNOW ON IS?
TO TOUCH.
BECAUSE THIS SENIOR WAS KIND OF
BEING THERE.
BEING TARGETED.
SO YOU KNOW IS THIS A SICKNESSES
WILL ACQUIT CALLER THE SENIORS
CAMPUS REALLY GOING AFTER. DOLE
ALTHOUGH SCAMMERS Y. AND AND THE
BANK AND DO IT I'M.
VERY CONFIDENT THAT THOSE WIRE
HAS THROUGH A COMPANY BE ABLE TO
DO IT WIDER.
AT AT THE COUNTER WHERE THERE'S
A HUMAN INTERACTION OR AND IN
THE BACK IN OR DO YOU JUST
POINTED OUT IN THE AND INTO
CORPORATE OFFICE OR.
SOME OF THE THUMB. YEAH
LOCATIONS SAID DEFINITELY I
WOULD ASSUME I AND I DON'T KNOW
A LOT ABOUT THIS BUSINESS IS
ALWAYS THE DIFFICULTY OF THE
WORK THAT WE DO. ON A MILE WIDE
AND STEEP RIGHT.
BUT WERE YOU KNOW HOLDING.
COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE FOR
TRANSACTIONS AND PATTERNS THAT
THEY MAY SEE THAT I GET I THINK
HOLDING INDIVIDUALS.
ACCOUNTABLE FOR A LIMITED
INTERACTION THAT THEY MAY HAVE
ONLY ONCE IT'S ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT. COURSE WE WOULD HOPE
EXPECTED PEOPLE TO SPEAK GOOD
DECENT HUMAN BEINGS THAT THEY
SEE A SENIOR BEING MANIPULATED
THAT THEY WOULD SAY SOMETHING A
CALL RIGHT. OVERLY WHICH IS
CREATING IS AN ONUS FOR THAT
EMPLOYEE TO DO SOMETHING AND MY
SUSPICION IS THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO REALLY NARROWED DOWN TO
SOMEONE WHO'S A BIT MORE
SPECIALIZED MAYBE HAS A MORE. ON
INFORMED.
INTERACTION WITH THAT
INDIVIDUAL RATHER THAN JUST SORT
OF RETAIL EXPERIENCE I THINK ALL
OF US WOULD FEEL. AT A DEFICIT
AT LEAST YOU KNOW CONCERNED THAT
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO FOR
PERFORMED EXPECTATIONS OF US IF
WE WERE. DOES NEED A MANDATED
REPORTER I'M SO THOSE ARE THE
GENERAL CONCERNS I I HEARD YOU
SAY YOU COULD TALK A BIT MORE
ABOUT THAT OF THE KIND OF MAN
THAT YOU LOOKING TO TAKE IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE. ON BECAUSE I
RECOGNIZE WE HAVE SOME DEADLINES
AND IN THEIR SOME NEEDS IT TO
TAKE ACTION BUT WHAT IS IT
YOU'RE HOPING TO GO THE NEXT
MINUTE THEY'RE DO YOU DO ONE OR
HOLDEN FOR THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE IS TO CLARIFY. THAT
ANY FINE THOSE ARE IMPOSED ON
THE COMPANY NOT THE. EMPLOYEES
ARE NOT NOT THE CLERK. WILL BE
HAPPY TO.
OF BROADER DID RANGE OF
FIGHTING THE SCAMMERS.
UTILIZING THIS BILL I LIKE WE'RE
GOING WITH THAT BECAUSE YOU KNOW
IF YOU'RE OF OF OF FIND A HUGE
FINE TO A MINIMUM WAGE EMPLOYEES
IN UNLESS THEY'RE SUPER AWARE OF
WHAT THEY'RE UP TO.
THEN I I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT'S
THE RIGHT THING BUT I ALSO THINK
IT'S ABOUT NARROWING THE SCOPE
OF IT WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
WHO'S ACTUALLY HELD ACCOUNTABLE
TO THIS.
I THINK YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
SOME OF THE WIRE SERVICES AS
OPPOSED TO SOME OF THE RETAILERS
I THINK YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
SOME OF THE FOLKS IN THE BACK
INTO REALLY CAN BE MONITORING
THIS AS OPPOSED TO SOMEONE. WHO
THIS MAY BE ONE OF HUNDREDS OF
TRANSACTIONS THEY MAY DO A DAY
ON THAT AGAIN ARE NOT OF THE
SAME CALIBER OR INTERACTION THAT
I MAY HAVE WITH MY BANK TELLER?
I'M WITH THE DEALING ONE KIND OF
THING ALL DAY LONG THEY SEE ME
EVERY NOW AGAIN AND THEY CAN
PICK UP THE KIND OF PATTERN THAT
I THINK WE'RE EXPECTING PEOPLE
TO OBSERVE. AND TAKE ACTION I
THINK THAT'S WHAT YOUR INTENT IS
THAT'S INTENT I CAN PUBLIC IT
WITH THAT.
BUT THERE'S GONNA BE SOME OF
WHAT I HEAR YOUR COMMITMENT TO
DO THAT BUT LIMITED SCOPE WITH
REDUCTIONS IN MY ABILITY
PARTICULAR AGAIN FOR FRONTLINE
WORKERS WHO I DON'T KNOW THAT
THEY WOULD NECESSARILY KNOW. AND
ONE THING I WOULD SAY OBSERVING
AND READING THIS BILL ANOTHER
BEEN SIMILAR EFFORTS WITH HOTEL
WORKERS TO TRY AND EDUCATE THEM
TO SAY OBSERVE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
PATTERNS AND TO TRY AND TAKE
ACTION. AGAIN IS NOT MAKING THE
MANDATED REPORTERS OR MAKING
THEM LIABLE BUT IS ABOUT
EDUCATING THEM TO WITNESS
PATTERNS AND TO TAKE ACTION I
THINK THAT'S WHAT WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE WHICH IS SOMETHING
AND ALSO I WOULD BE SUPPORTIVE
OF. HER AND OF IKE AND I COULD
ASSEMBLY GLORIA POEM MUCH OF THE
CONVERSATIONS THE LAST COUPLE
DAYS OF WHAT SOME WHICH WAS
OFFICES BEEN BASED UPON. A
FEEDBACK FROM THE SENATE MEMBERS
OFFICES.
WHEN THEY FIRST HAND
OPPORTUNITY LEARN MORE ABOUT THE
BILL AND SO SOME OF THE
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS AS ON THE
SHOES AGREED TO FIRST OF ALL
THAT. ONE OF THE PERSONS
REFERRED TO IN REGARDS TO WORK
WITH THE BANKERS ASSOCIATION TO
GET THEM TO REMOVE DUBBED THE
BANKERS OPPOSITION TO IT.
A BECAUSE OF THEIR ALREADY THEY
ALREADY HAVE THAT OBLIGATION
INTO TO NOT MUDDY THE WATERS
THERE ARE THEIR ALREADY EXISTING
OBLIGATION SEKALI TO REMOVE
INDIVIDUAL INDEPENDENT
LIABILITY.
BUT THIRD ALSO TO TELL TO FOCUS
ON IN ON THOSE ARE ACTUALLY
DOING THE TRANSACTIONS BECAUSE.
OF THE BELIEF
IS THIS IS STILL CONSUMER
PROTECTION SENIOR PROTECTION
BILL IN THE REALITY IS THAT. ON
THE ONE HAND YES YOU COULD SAY
THAT THESE ARE LIMITED
TRANSACTIONS ON THE OTHER HAND
AS STATED BY OPPOSITION A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS. A HUNDRED TWENTY
BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY SENDING
MONEY FROM A IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES IN A TO OTHER.
COUNTRIES THAT AYE AYE GOOD
IDEA THAT THERE'S GOT TO BE SOME
KIND OF OBLIGATION IN TRAINING
BEYOND.
THAT THAT DOESN'T PUT THE
LIABILITY ON THE INDIVIDUAL BUT.
IS NOT TO THE EXTENT NECESSARY
WITH BANKERS BUT WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER A LOT OF THE TELLERS
THAT WORK IN BANKS ALSO.
YOU KNOW THERE MIGHT BE COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND I BE FOLKS WORKING
PART TIME THAT MAY NOT KNOW
EVERYONE THAT COMES BEFORE THEM
GET THEY HAVE THAT OBLIGATION.
AND AND THIS INDUSTRY IS
SPECIFIC AND A SPECIFICALLY
TARGETS DOES.
BECAUSE OF THAT BECAUSE OF THE
NEEDS AS INDICATED IN IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES WE DON'T HAVE ANY
OTHER OPTIONS A SON THAT MONEY
AND SO I'D THAT'S PART OF THE
REASON WHY BASED UPON.
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS AS WELL AS
THE BACK OF THESE COMMUNITIES
NEED TO BE PROTECTED FROM THE
FROM THE ABUSE PARTICULAR WASN'T
PARTICULARLY THE SENIORS. THAT'S
THAT'S CONSTANTLY OCCURRING AND
I KNOW THAT.
LOUIS WE DIDN'T IF THERE'S DATA
YOU WANT ME WE HAVE DATA WE CAN
GET FROM THE APARTMENT TERMS OF
THE AMOUNT OF FRAUD. THAT OCCURS
WITH SENIORS BUT I THINK THAT
THIS IS REALLY TRY TO IDENTIFY A
VERY NUANCED.
FOCUS ON ON ONE ASPECT OF SENIOR
FRAUD WHICH IS CHALLENGING TO DO
GIVEN THE BUSINESS MODEL BUT I
THAT THAT'S A CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE HAD. WE'VE HAD WITH THE
AUTHOR OF ALL THE AUTHOR IN HIS
OFFICE BECAUSE IT IS GOING TO
JUDICIARY KNACKS WHICH I SAID
ON.
AND SO CERTAINLY SOMEBODY'S CAR
BY MEMBERS WOULD BE REQUIRED OF
FLOOD OF ME AND. OUR STAFF HERE
BUT AS PART OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
ENSURE THAT THEY'RE DONE BEFORE
IT GETS TO JUDICIARY AND I'LL
INFORM THE CHARGE ISSUE THAT AS
WELL THOUGH OBVIOUSLY KNOW
WHAT'S BEEN COMMITTED TO.
SERBIA.
THOUGH PART THAT I'M STRUGGLING
WITH IS I THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS IF I'M A
YOUNG YOU KNOW.
KID WORKING IN THE STORE THAT
MAY NOT BE A REPUTABLE BANK AND
I AND THE STORE GETS FINED
BECAUSE WHO LOSES THEIR JOB. IS
THAT THE THE PERSON THAT DATA
ARE EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE NOT FINE
DIRECTLY.
THE THESE COMPANIES THAT WORK
ON LOSSES AND THEY MIGHT.
YOU KNOW.
FIRE THAT.
PERSON FOR NOT BEING MORE AWARE
AND IF WE DON'T HAVE YOU KNOW
KIND OF A MANDATE FOR TRACKING
TRAINING OR. BLOOD LET'S FACE IT
SOME OF US YOU KNOW THAT ARE A
LITTLE BIT MORE EXPERIENCE CAN
FEED AS BY A LOT YOU KNOW IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT PART TIME
WORKERS COLLEGE STUDENTS OR
SOMEBODY THAT DOESN'T HAVE THE
EXPERIENCE. AND THAT'S WHERE MY
STRUGGLE IS.
AS WELL AS AS.
THE THE MANDATE PART OF IT.
.
EVEN THOUGH OF WHEN WE MANDATE.
THERE'S A DOZEN.
THE ROOT OF THE PROBLEM IS THE
SCAMMERS IN THESE FIELDS ARE NOT
THE SCAMMERS THAT THE SCAMMERS
ARE NOT BEING ADDRESSED THE
SCAMS JR SCAMMERS ARE STILL OUT
THERE IN. AND SO I SEE WHERE
YOU'RE GOING WITH THIS BUT I
DON'T SEE THE PROTECTION AND.
IF THE SCAMMERS ARE NOT BEING
COCKED.
BECAUSE WE HAVE NO ASSURANCES
THAT YOU CAN FIND THOSETHE
STORES OR WHOEVER IT IS FOR THE
TRANSMITTAL BUTTOCK SCAMMERS ARE
NOT. BEING CAUGHT AND AT THE END
SO THE SCAMMERS STILL GOT THE
SCAM AND THEN HERE YOU KNOW WE
MIGHT HAVE A SOMEBODY THAT'S
LOSING THEIR JOB BECAUSE. OF NOT
CATCHING THAT SO THAT'S WHY I'M
STRUGGLING WITH THAT AND SO.
THIS WILL DEFINITELY TRYING TO%
FIRST THE FIRST STEP IS TO
REPORT THE CRIME.
AND THEN THE HOPEFULLY THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT WOULD DO DARE THE TO
DILIGENT TO CATCH TO SING
SCAMMERS.
SO THIS ONE WAS JUST RECALL OF A
FROM LYING. TO. TO PUT DECIMAL
OR REQUIREMENT TO THE BANK
TELLER TO THOSE PEOPLE DATA SAID
BEHIND IT. WIRED TRANSMITTER.
OFFICE.
NO BUT WOULD UNDERSTAND THAT THE
DAYS DUE DO. DOUG D'AMATO YOU
KNOW YOU'LL YOU'LL SINGLE AND I
AM A MACHINE OR A TELEPHONE.
BUT I'M HOPING THAT.
THOSE PEOPLE ON THE OTHER END
OF THE TELEPHONE ALSO BE TRYING
TO IDENTIFY. USER HEY YOU'RE
SENDING THIS ONE TO SOME
COUNTRIES AND.
AFRICA YOU KNOW AND AND YOU
WOULD BE ABLE TO.
.
TAKE A LITTLE BIT LOGO MORE
RESPONSIBLE HEALTH REPORTING.
THOSE TRANSACTIONS.
CHAIR I'M SORRY I'M SORRY
THERE'S WOULDN'T COULDN'T NO
QUESTION POSED.
ADDS I'D OPPORTUNITY FOR OF
THAT THANK YOU.
.
THAT.
IF THERE'S NO OTHER VIABLE
QUESTION OR COMMENT RIGHT NOW.
.
YOU KNOW I HAVEN'T I
RECOMMENDATION BECAUSE OF THE
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS THAT SOME
ISSUES AGREED TO TAKE AS WELL AS
THE FURTHER WORK. ON FURTHER
FOCUSING AND I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT LOOK.
.
YES THERE ARE LOT
RESPONSIBILITIES ON BANKERS AND
TELLERS WHAT HAVE YOU YET THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT'S FLOWING
THROUGH.
THIS.
THESE COMPANIES ALL IT REQUIRES
SOME OBLIGATION AS WELL AND IF
THE BUSINESS PRACTICES THAT
WHILE THEY JUST GET GROCERY
STORES TO HAVE. MAWAE'S WORKERS
DOING IT THAT'S DOESN'T REMOVE
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF.
OF TRYING TO IDENTIFY CONDUCT
AGAIN JUST IDENTIFYING IT.
AND BEING PROPERLY TRAINED AND
THE QUESTION THEN GOES TO WELL
HOW DO YOU IDENTIFY IT YOU'RE
TRAINED HANDS THERE'S GOTTA BE
SOME. LEVEL OF TRAINING IN THE
MANDATORY REPORTING OBVIOUSLY IS
ALWAYS A REASONABLE TEST OF
THAT.
IF A IF A FRAUD GETS THROUGH A
BANK TELLER IT'S ALL EITHER
AUTOMATICALLY LIABLE. IT'S THAT
DAY THERE'S GOTTA BE A JUDGMENT
AS TO WHETHER THEY WOULD TO A
REASONABLE BANG TELL WOULD HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO IDENTIFY.
I'M. GLAD THAT YOU CAN GET TO
THAT OF THAT BANK TELLER IS NOT
PROPERLY TRAINED.
THIS GOES TO TRAINING.
IN INDUSTRY.
OF THE DIED DOESN'T HAVE THE
SAME REGULATIONS AND CHECKS THE
BANKING INDUSTRY HAS AND THAT'S
THE REASON WHY. I AYE RECOMMEND
I RECOMMENDATION BECAUSE.
IN ADDITION TO THE CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS THAT.
THAT HAS EMERGED TO PUT FORWARD
TO FURTHER NARROW IT.
TO REMOVE INDIVIDUAL LIABILITY
AND.
TO WORK WITH THE BANKERS TO
REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION AS WELL.
THIS SHOE OBJECT CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
YOU KNOW PRETTY MUCH OUTSIDE
MOVED CONTINUE WORKING. OF WOOD
WITH THE.
.
D..
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE MEMBERS YOU
FELL.
AND ALSO DE.
DUE. OF THE BANKERS ASSOCIATION
TO CLARIFY. AND TO.
FOR SUCH AS HOME AMENDMENTS.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE BOAT.
OKAY THANK YOU I'M IS OUR
MOTION.
.
JERRY IF WE HADN'T QUESTION
COMMENT BUT I WORK YEAH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WAS HERE I HAVE A
COMMENT FOR.
CERTAINLY HAVE GOTTEN SOME
CALLS MY DISH WITH RESPECT TO
THE BILL. AND MY OFFICE TRY TO
COMMUNICATE THAT'S TO IN FACT
THE AUTHOR WITH RESPECT TO HIS
BILL. AND CERTAINLY FOR THE
REASONS THAT OF OUR BEING TICKET
WE ARTICULATED BY. MS RUBIO.
SOME OF MY CONCERNS.
I AM.
HOPEFUL THAT THOSE AMENDMENTS.
WILL IN FACT TO BE PUT FORTH I
UNDERSTAND THIS BILL ALSO TO.
BE DOUBLE REFERRED TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
AND THAT.
WHAT I'M HERE FROM THE CHAIR IS
A COMMITMENT?
ON YOUR PART TO WORK WITH.
THE AUTHOR.
AS YOU SIT ON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
I TRY TO TAKE CONSIDERATION
CERTAINLY MR GLORIOSO MR
GLORIA'S.
COMMENTS.
WHICH I THINK ARE ARE VERY
TARGETED VERY SPECIFIC AND ALSO
MS RUBIO BECAUSE WE DIDN'T TALK
ABOUT FOR ME. IN AND I'M
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT. A PERSON
WHO IN FACT.
WORKS FOR A PARTICULAR X.
DOUBTLESS MADE EVEN THOUGH THAT
PERSON THEMSELVES WOULD NOT BE
THE ONE. RECEIVING THE FINAL BE
THE COMPANY AND THE COMPANY
COULD. OF COURSE MINIMIZE THEIR
LIABILITY.
BECAUSE THEY'VE JUST RECEIVED A
FINE AND THIS PERSON SHOULD BE
TRAINED AND NOW THAT PERSON
POTENTIALLY COULD BE UNEMPLOYED
AS A RESULT OF THAT.
BUT I DO THINK THAT AND I
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE SPIRIT
IN WHICH.
THIS BILL WAS BROUGHT FORWARD I
DO THINK THAT THERE'S SOME. WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
HERE.
AND CERTAINLY AND ENCOURAGE BY
AGAIN THE CHAIRS.
POSITION HIS COMMENTS TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR.
INJURE DASH
AND SO I WILL BE DOING A
COURTESY I I'LL MAKE A MOTION. I
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT.
IS GOING TO MOVE FORWARD IF IN
FACT IT'S OUT OF COMMITTEE AND
YOUR COMMITMENT TO WORKING ON
STRONG STRENGTH IN THIS BILL
BECAUSE. AND I RESERVE MY RIGHT
ON THE FLOOR GETS A FLOOR TO DO
SOMETHING ELSE DIFFERENT.
HOW DO A SECOND ON THAT? AND BUT
THE COMMITMENT THAT I WILL WORK
WITH THE WHEELCHAIR STONE AYE
AYE AYE SHARE CONCERNS THAT ARE
RAISED HERE AND I THINK THAT
THERE IS MORE WORK THAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE. BUT I BELIEVE THAT.
.
BUT THEN THE SINCERITY OF HIS
ORIGINAL WORK ON THAT BUT I ALSO
BELIEVE THAT. IF.
THERE'S NOT FURTHER FOCUS ON IT
THAT IT.
OF THE LONG GETTING TO THE
FLOOR.
MAY VERY WELL NOT MAKE IT TO
JUDICIARY IT'S ABOUT SOMETHING I
THINK BE WELL ALL BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH SUMMER ISSUE AND WITH
CHAIR STONE TO. CONTINUE TO DEAL
WITH THAT SOME OF THE CONCERNS
RAISED HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
BUT IT'S UGH GOING TO TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE THANK YOU.
KALRA. AYE
KALRA AYE VOEPEL RESPECTFUL NO.
VOEPEL NO. ALLEN. CABALLERO.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE. GLORIA. RUBIO.
GLORIA I MEAN SORRY RUBIO NOT
VOTING.
OKAY SO WELL WILL LOVE THEM.
KEEP THAT YOU HAVE A WILL HOLD
THAT OPEN A.
BEHOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THAT AS
BEING A WAY TO CUT MORE MEMBERS.
AND.
.
GO ON TO ASSEMBLY ISSUES OTHER
BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I CHAIRED A
MEMBER A. B. THREE ZERO EIGHT
EIGHT REQUIRE. ALL CONTINUING
CARE RETIREMENT COMMUNITY.
CC RC TO STUDY BEING BAKED
PUNISHER RISK SUCH SHOWS THAT
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE COSTS. IN
IT IN DEAR FACILITY TO BETTER
PLAYING FOR. AN IMPENDING COST
AND LIMITED FUND ISSUE IMPACT TO
THE PRESIDENT BY A ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL.
Y. HAVE DAY.
ATTEST TO TEST THEIR TWO
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
IS I'M A MORGAN. OF KHOBAR WHOLE
AND DATA OF A MODERATE GRIFFIN'S
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CONTINUING CARE RESIDENTS
ASSOCIATION.
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MARGARET GRIFFIN
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONTINUING CARE PRECEDENTS
ASSOCIATION OR CAL CROW.
AND A THIRTEEN YEAR RESIDENT OF
UNIVERSITY RETIREMENT COMMUNITY
CCRC IN DAVIS.
CALPERS THE SOUL ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING SENIORS LIVING IN
CC ARE SEIZING CALIFORNIA OUR
MISSION IS TO ENHANCE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE AND FINANCIAL
SECURITY OF CCRC RESIDENTS.
AS RESIDENTS WHEN WE MOVED INTO
A CCRC WE PAID AN ENTRANCE FEE.
WE CONTINUE TO PAY AND ONGOING
MONTHLY FEE WHICH IS SUBJECT TO
INCREASES AT THE DISCRETION OF
OUR PROVIDER.
IN ADDITION TO COVERING
OPERATING COSTS THESE MONTHLY
FEES INCLUDE INCREASES TO HELP
COVER THE COST OF MAINTENANCE
AND REPAIRS AT OUR FACILITIES.
AB THIRTY ABA THIS IMPORTANT TO
RESIDENTS AS INSURERS THAT OUR
PROVIDERS ARE USING RESPONSIBLE
PLANNING TOOLS TO MAINTAIN
FINANCIAL SOLVENCY AT OUR
FACILITIES.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE STATISTICAL
MODELING FINANCIAL RISK
ASSESSMENT. THAT IS PROVIDED BY
AN ACTUARIAL STUDY OR VALUABLE
TOOLS THAT SHOULD BE UTILIZED BY
ALL CRC OFFERS.
ALL C. C. R. C.'S MAINTAIN
INDEPENDENT LIVING ASSISTED
LIVING IN SKILLED NURSING UNITS
ON CAMPUS.
AND THE PROMISE TO ACCOMMODATE
THEIR RESIDENTS AS THEY AGE.
OUR INHERENT IN ALL CONTRACTS.
WITHOUT AN ACTUARIAL STUDY OF
CCRC MAY APPEAR FINANCIALLY
STABLE IN THE SHORT TERM.
YET STILL FACE SIGNIFICANT
THREATS TO ITS LONG TERM
VIABILITY.
JUSTICE ACTUARIAL STUDIES FOCUS
ON THE BUSINESS SIDE OF AN
OPERATION THERE'S ALSO A NEED TO
ATTEND TO THE PHYSICAL PLANT AND
EQUIPMENT OF A FACILITY.
IGNORING OR DEFERRING
MAINTENANCE ISSUES GUARANTEES
THAT WHEN FINALLY DISCOVERED THE
EVENTUAL REPAIRS WILL ONLY GET
MORE SEVERE AND EXPENSIVE AS
TIME GOES BY.
THEREFORE IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
ALL C. C. R. C.'S REGULARLY
OBTAINED A MAINTENANCE AND
REPAIR REVIEW OF THESE IMPORTANT
BUILDING SYSTEMS.
HAVING THE INFORMATION PROVIDED.
BY THE LONG TERM PLANNING TOOLS
THAT A. B. THIRTY EIGHTY A WILL
ALLOW MANAGEMENT TO BE MORE
FULLY AWARE. OF THE STRENGTHS
AND WEAKNESSES. OF THEIR CCRC AS
A WHOLE. AND TO BE PROACTIVE AND
EFFECTIVE. IN ALLOCATING
RESOURCES TO MEET THOSE NEEDS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME MY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS MISSION.
I THINK IT.
THANK YOU COMMUTING AND
CONSULTANTS AND MORNING CARVE
ALTERNATIVE STRATEGY GROUP ALSO
BE HAVE CALCRAFT NOT BE VERY
SHORT AND BRIEF I JUST WANT
EXPAND ON TWO POINTS MENTIONED
IN THE ANALYSIS. FIRST THAT THE
STATUTE SILENT ON THE COMPONENTS
OF THE ACTUARIAL STUDY REQUIRED
FOR THE BELL. WHILE THIS IS TRUE
THERE IS A NATIONAL STANDARD OF
PRACTICE THAT APPLIES ACTUARIES
WHEN PERFORMING PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES.
INCLUDING GIVING ADVICE THAT
SIR SPECIFICALLY I GEARED
TOWARDS EASIER SEIZE BOTH FOR A
FOR PROFIT AND NONPROFIT.
THE STANDARDS ARE SET BY THE
ACTUARIAL STANDARDS BOARD AND
INCLUDE A RANGE OF FACTORS TO
CONSIDER INCLUDING TESTING THE
FINANCIAL CONDITION OF CCRC.
ESTIMATING ASSETS AND
LIABILITIES EVALUATING FEE
STRUCTURES.
DEVELOPING POPULATION
PROJECTIONS AND MUCH MORE.
SECOND IS THAT THE SEIZE
EUROPEAN THE A CCRC PROVIDERS
ALREADY PROVIDE FINANCIAL
INFORMATION OF THAT APARTMENT ON
AND
WELL BASIS.
FOR THE MAJORITY OF CZ R. C.'S
ACTUARIAL STUDIES ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO BE CONDUCTED ARE
REPORTED TO THE DEPARTMENT.
ACTUARIES UNLIKE AUDITED
FINANCIAL REPORTS ARE FORWARD
THINKING GAUGING THE RISK OF
FINANCIAL FUTURE FINANCIAL
LIABILITIES. WOULD STRONGLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT AND THIRTY EIGHTY.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ALSO SUPPORT.
YES MY NAME IS BILL SURE ARE I'M
A RESIDENT WHOSE CCRC IN DAVIS
AND I SUPPORT THOSE.
ROBERT SWENSON I AM A RESIDENT
OF.
CCRC IN DAVIS CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
I TONY TO GET THERE WITH
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR NURSING
HOME REFORM IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME CANYON M. UNIMPRESSIVE
AND SHE'S EVER SEEN DAVIS AND
WAS AS CHAIRMAN LOCAL CHAPTER
CAL CRAP I SUPPORTED HIM.
THEM PRESCOTT WILLIAMS A
RESIDENT OF UNIVERSITY
RETIREMENT COMMUNITY I SUPPORT
THE BILL.
THANK YOU ANYWAY IN OPPOSITION
.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JET
HAMPTON PARA PRISON NEEDS
CALIFORNIA.
REGRETTABLY IN OPPOSITION TO.
AB THREE ZERO EIGHT EIGHT.
FIRST I THINK THE OFFERING BOTH
FORWARD AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFFER.
ALL TOWARDS THEY PUT INTO THEIR
COMMAND HOUSES ON THIS BILL.
YOU KNOW THE TO START BY
ESSENTIALLY.
.
MISSION THIS IS YOUR SEATS OFFER
SEVERAL DIFFERENT CONTRACT TYPES
IN DIFFERENT SERVICES.
CURRENTLY IN THE CURRENT STATUTE
CAESAR'S YOU ARE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE AN ACTUARIAL STUDY ON
ALL.
COMMUNITIES TO PROVIDE TYPE A
CONTRACTS
TAIPEI CONTRACTS.
TYPICALLY REQUIRE A
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
INTRINSICALLY THE HIGHER BUT
STABLE MONTHLY FEES.
BUT UNLIMITED AN ALL INCLUSIVE
SERVICES.
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR LIFE.
THEY ALSO INCLUDE A VERY
IMPORTANT COMPONENT WHICH IS A
REALLY TRIGGERS NATURAL STUDY IN
ED IS A PROMISSORY NOTE OF CARE.
MEAN THAT IF THE INDIVIDUAL.
ANY TYPE A CONTRACT WHO.
MAY OUT LIVE THEIR ENTRANCE
SEEING THEIR RESOURCES THE CCRC
STUFF FINANCIALLY OBLIGATED TO
CARE FOR THAT INDIVIDUAL FOR
LIFE WHETHER AGAIN THEY'VE
OUTLIVED THE RESOURCES OR THE
CAN NO LONGER MAKE THE MONTHLY
FEE.
THIS IS WHY TYPICALLY AN
ACTUARIAL STUDY IS TRIGGERED FOR
THESE TYPE ES CONTRACTS.
.
FOR THE OTHER CONTRACT TYPES
TYPE BICU TYPE C. CONTRACTS
THERE EITHER MODIFIED OR FEE FOR
SERVICE CONTRACT TYPES WERE THE
RESIDENT TYPICALLY.
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR IT FUNDING
THEIR HEALTHCARE NEEDS.
SO.
WHILE.
WE APPRECIATE THE.
STATEMENTS THAT THE.
THE PROPONENTS ARE MAKING ON
THIS BILL.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
ACTUARIAL STUDIES PRIMARILY
FOCUS ON FUNDING FUTURE HEALTH
CARE OBLIGATIONS.
AND THOSE ARE NOT PRESENT IN
TYPING TYPES HE CONTRACTS.
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT REQUIRING
SEIZE YOUR SEIZE
THAT PROVIDE.
THAT DO NOT PROVIDE TYPE A
CONTRACTS.
TO DO NATURAL STUDY.
IS NOT ONLY LESS UNNECESSARY
BUT IS ALSO COSTLY.
TYPICALLY WHEN THE OPERATIONAL
COST OF THE FACILITY GO UP THOSE
FEES ARE TO PASS ON THE
RESIDENTS SO WE WOULD. WE ARE
OPPOSE THE IDEA OF THE CENTURY
HAVING A CITY THAT WOULD BE
UNNECESSARY PROVIDE NOMINAL OR
NO BENEFICIAL INFORMATION.
AND POTENTIALLY REYES RESIDENT
FEES.
.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT
WHEN IT COMES TO THE.
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
INFORMATION THE CCRC PROVIDE ON
A YEARLY BASIS AS HE ANNOUNCES
POINTS OUT. US YOU SEE OR HEAR
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT ANNUAL
REPORTS CONSISTING OF AUDITED
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS.
AND REQUIRED RESERVE
CALCULATIONS WITH THE CERTIFIED
PUBLIC COUNTS OPINION.
ADDITIONAL REVENUE RESERVE
INFORMATION.
EVIDENCE REALLY BONTA CLICKABLE.
FURTHERMORE I IT WAS STATED
THAT.
ACTUAL CITIES ARE FORWARD
THINKING.
BUT IT IS REQUIRED TO SEIZE YOUR
SEIZE PROVIDES FINANCIAL
COMMISSION ON A YEARLY BASIS
LOOKING BACK FIVE YEARS. AS WELL
AS LOOKING FORWARD FIVE YEARS.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT.
THE FINANCIAL INFORMATION IS
PROVIDED BY THE CCRC IS
CURRENTLY ARE ALREADY.
INCORPORATED IN IN IN THE
INFORMATION PROVIDED TO D. SS ON
REGULAR BASIS FURTHERMORE DSS
HAS THE ABILITY. TO. REACH OUT
TO THE PROVIDER IF THEY'RE SEEN
FINANCIAL TRENDS THAT ARE
TROUBLESOME AND WORK FOR THE
PROVIDER.
TO TO CREATE THOSE AS NECESSARY.
LASTLY.
WHILE WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THE MEN THE INFAMOUS OVERTAKEN
IN TE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE.
LOOKING AT AT THE MAINTENANCE
REVIEW.
WE WOULD ALSO ARGUE THAT THIS
MAY BE AYE UNNECESSARY AS
SEIZURES THESE ARE ALREADY
COUNTING FOR MANY OF THESE
FACTORS WHEN THEY'RE DOING THEIR
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT BUDGETS AND
CREATING A CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT
PLAN.
OUR CONCERN WITH THE LANGUAGE I
REGARDING THE MAIN INTERVIEW IS
THAT IS.
VERY PRESCRIPTIVE AND IT LEAVES
A LITTLE FLEXIBILITY FOR THE
PROVIDER WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THINGS LIKE.
A TWENTY YEAR LIFESPAN OF.
PARK BENCH OR OR OR SEEN ON
THOSE LINES INTO SEIZURES HE
MADE CHOOSE TO FIX THAT EARLIER
WITH ANY CHOOSE TO DELAYED IF
IT'S SOME GOOD WORKING FUNCTIONS
OF THE SPECIFIC THE SPECIFICITY
OF THAT. IS PROBLEMATIC.
WITH WITH THAT WE HAVE WITH
THAT BEING SAID BEING AGES POST.
THINK YOU.
ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS LEFT ON THE
OPPOSITION SIDE SO I THOUGHT HE
HAD AYE I THINK YOU MADE THOSE
ARGUMENTS COMPLETE.
HEATHER HARRISON AT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSISTED LIVING
ASSOCIATION A WERE ALSO.
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE TO THE
SPELL.
I'D ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY
MY COLLEAGUE THESE OUT
COMMUNITIES PROVIDE TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF FINANCIAL INFORMATION
DSS MONITORS THEM THEY CAN STEP
IN. THE FINANCIAL REPORTING DOES
LOOK FORWARD AND OUT OF THE
CAPITAL EXPENDITURE PIECE DOES
HAPPEN TODAY IN THE BUDGET
CONVERSATIONS AND IN THE KEY
INDICATOR REPORTS.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY HOW OPPOSE.
THANK YOU OR ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY SO WILL BRING IT OF BACKING
A TO THE COMMITTEE FUNNY CAO
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS WE DO HAVE
A MOTION.
OKAY AND SO.
.
CAN BE A BILL MOTION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THERE IS A
MOTION ARE THOSE IDEAS VIA.
OKAY AND SO.
SHE LIKE OPPOSE.
YOU HAVE TO AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH EITHER AGAIN TO JUST.
.
RAIL WAS TRYING TO.
REQUIRED THAT CCRC TO PROVIDE.
.
THE THE THE.
PRETTY MUCH I'M DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE COSTS AND THEIR
FACILITIES SO WE CAN BETTER PLAN
DO YOU. IMPENDING BECAUSE I LIVE
IN THE FINANCIAL IMPACT WHO DID
RESIDENTS. SO'S NOT JUST TO THE
FINANCIAL RISKS BUT WE'RE TRYING
TO EARLY OF DO A GOOD.
GREAT A ASSESSMENT TO THE.
CONDITION OFF THE DE. A.
DEAR DEAR OF FACILITY SO TO BE
BETTER PLAN FOR ANY.
.
IMPENDING BECAUSE SO I
RESPECTFULLY AS WE ARE ABLE.
OKAY UP THANK YOU WE DO THERE IS
AN AYE RECOMMENDATION. OF NEW
I THINK THAT.
.
HAVING THE ACTUAL OPINION ONCE
EVERY FIVE YEARS IS AN. OVERLY
ONEROUS AND AND I'M SURE THAT
AND ALSO BASED UPON SOME OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT. WERE DONE TO
HUMAN SERVICES IN THE WORK OF
CHAIR RUBIO.
AND HUMAN SERVICES SUMMIT THAT
IF WE CAN HAVE A ROLL CALL VOTE
PLEASE.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I.
ALAN.
CABALLERO.
GIPSON.
ABSENT AYE GLORIA.
GLORY AYE RUBIO AYE. RUBIO AYE.
OPEN FOR MEMBERS WHO HAVE NOT
VOTED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AS.
ALRIGHT LET'S SEE WHAT WE HAVE
NOW RUBIO.
IS.
IT ARE COLOR MATCHES LOADED ON
IT.
SOMEBODY WANTS TO GO HOME.
RUN AIDS
WHO DO WE HAVE NO.
WHO DO WE HAVE NOW?
I JUST JUST SO ARE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF THIS IS THE ONLY
COMMITTEE WHO WERE HAVING. NO
SOURCES ONE COMMITTEE WE DO ALL
THE ONE TIME RIGHT RIGHT FIFTH
AT THE.
.
WELL INTO THE SENATE BILLS COME
OVER BUT YOU NO LEASES ONE POINT
COMMITTEE HEARING.
THREE ABOUT ITEM FIVE IS A
RUBIO AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR
PLEASE THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO DAMN
PRESENTING AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
FOUR WHICH SEEKS TO PROTECT.
ELDERLY AND DEPENDENT ADULTS
FROM THE UNAUTHORIZED TAKING
SHARING OR POSTING OF DEGRADING
AND DEHUMANIZING PHOTOGRAPHS OR
VIDEOS. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE CHAIR COMMITTEE STAFF AND
THE ADVOCATES AND SUPPORT. AND
IN OPPOSITION FOR WORKING WITH
MY STAFF ARE ON THE AMENDMENTS.
TO THIS BILL.
THEN YOU OUGHT THEIR AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THAT PUBLIC SHAMING DOES
NOT INCLUDE THE TAKING SHARING
OR POSTING OF AN IMAGE OF AN
ELDER OR DEPENDENT ADULT FOR
CLINICAL SAFETY LEGAL OR
REPORTING PURPOSES. THAT ARE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE FEDERAL
HIPAA REGULATIONS.
THIS BILL COMES AS A RESULT OF
NUMEROUS CASES
SOME WITHIN MY OWN DISTRICT IN
WHICH INDIVIDUALS AND TRUSTED TO
TAKE CARE OF THESE VULNERABLE
ADULTS HAVE GROSSLY TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF THE ROLE AS CARE
GIVERS.
I JUST LIKE I'D JUST LIKE MANY
OF YOU DID HERE TODAY WAS
SHOCKED TO LEARN HOW PEOPLE WHO
COMMIT AND WITNESS THESE
APPALLING ACTS OF ABUSE CAN THEN
WALK AWAY WITH LITTLE OR NOT AT
ALL LEGAL REPERCUSSIONS. AS OUR
SENIOR POPULATION GROWS
DRASTICALLY AND OUR SOCIAL MEDIA
KEEPS EXPANDING OUT WE HAVE A
MORAL OBLIGATION TO PROTECT
THESE VULNERABLE ADULTS INVEST
AS BEST AS WE CAN. HERE WITH ME
TODAY IS OUR SPONSOR LISA
COLEMAN WITH THE QUOTE LA
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE OB.
I CAN NEVER SAY THAT WORD. ON
THE ARMY PEOPLE AYE ASSOCIATION
AND RACHEL TATE.
WITH THE WIFE AND HEALTHY
EATING COALITION WHO SHARE OUR
HERE TO SHARE SOME EXAMPLES OF
SOCIAL SEEMING.
GOOD AFTERNOON LISA COLEMAN WITH
CALCUTTA CALIFORNIA LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION ON
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN SO THE
ADVOCATES IN LICENSE LONG TERM
CARE FACILITIES AND SKILLED
NURSING ASSISTED LIVING. AND
THEY ARE THE EYES AND THE EARS
FOR.
.
RESIDENTS IN THE FAMILIES LAST
YEAR IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN A
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN SPUR OF
THE MOMENT UP PROVIDED OVER
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
CONSULTATIONS TO INDIVIDUALS.
THEY MADE MORE THAN SIXTY FOUR
THOUSAND VISITS IN LONG TERM
CARE FACILITIES THEY
INVESTIGATED AND RESOLVED FORTY
TWO THOUSAND COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATIONS.
AND IT IT ALARMS ME THAT IN THE
LAST FOUR YEARS THE COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATIONS REGARDING ELDER
ABUSE BECAUSE CALIFORNIA HAS A
KIND OF A UNIQUE SITUATION AND
THAT THE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN. IS THE INITIAL
RESPONDER TO ELDER ABUSE
COMPLAINTS.
THAT IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS THE
COMPLAINTS WITH THE CATEGORY OF
ELDER ABUSE HAVE INCREASED FROM
TEN PERCENT TO TWENTY TWO
PERCENT.
TWENTY TWO PERCENT OF THE FORTY
TWO THOUSAND COMPLAINTS
CAME UNDER THE CODE OF ELDER
ABUSE.
NOW THIS ISN'T JUST A CALIFORNIA
PROBLEM
THIS IS A NATIONAL PROBLEM. AND
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE CENTER
FOR MEDICARE AND MEDICAID
RECOGNIZE THAT MENTAL SUFFERING
MENTAL ABUSE IS WHAT'S OCCURRING
WIN EIGHT BIT WHEN AN IMAGE IS
CAPTURED. AND IT IS PLACED IN A
SOCIAL MEDIA FOR THE HUMILIATION
OF THE PRESIDENT OR THE ELDER
ADULT.
AND SO WHILE THIS IS HAPPENING
AS AS A FEDERAL MANDATE IN
REGULATORY. ARE CALIFORNIA PENAL
CODE HAS NOT KEPT PACE WITH THE
CHANGE IN TECHNOLOGY AND THE
EASE AT WHICH ARE IMAGES CAN
KEEP CAN BE CAPTURED.
SO WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
OF.
WHEN THE OMBUDSMAN GAME AND SAID
THIS IS IMPORTANT SHE RECOGNIZE
THAT WE ARE IN FACT YOUR EYES
AND EARS.
AND.
SO TODAY TO GIVE YOU EXAMPLES
OF WHY THIS IS REALLY IS
HAPPENING I TURN OVER TO OUR
RACHEL TATE WAS A FIELD ON THE.
I THINK THE GRABBING ME AND MY
NAME IS RACHEL TATUM A REGIONAL
DIRECTOR WITH THE WISE AND
HEALTHY AGING LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM. SERVING OVER
SEVENTY SIX THOUSAND RESIDENTS
IN LONG TERM CARE IN THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES.
AND LAST YEAR WE INVESTIGATED
OVER TWELVE THOUSAND CASES
INVOLVING QUALITY OF LIFE AND
QUALITY OF CARE CONCERNS FOR
RESIDENTS IN LONG TERM CARE
SETTINGS.
WE'RE SEEING AN INCREASE IN
CASES WHERE FACILITIES STAFF
MEMBERS PHOTOGRAPH AND VIDEOTAPE
RESIDENTS WHO CLEARLY LACK THE
CAPACITY TO CONSENT TO SUCH
ACTIONS.
THESE PHOTOGRAPHS AND VIDEOS ARE
OFTEN USED TO MOCK RESIDENTS WHO
NEED ASSISTANCE WITH TOILETING
OR OTHER PERSONAL CARE NEEDS.
IN SOME CASES LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS TOLD THE
OMBUDSMAN THIS IS A CIVIL MATTER
AND THEY WON'T TAKE A REPORT OR
SEND ANYBODY TO INVESTIGATE.
OUR OFFICE RECEIVED A REPORT OF
A CAREGIVER TAKING A VIDEO OF A
NAKED OLDER GENTLEMEN ON THE
TOILET CRYING.
THE CAREGIVER COULD BE HEARD
LAUGHING AT THE RESIDENT IN THE
VIDEO. THE VIDEO WAS TRANSMITTED
VIA SOCIAL MEDIA TO THE
CAREGIVERS FRIENDS.
ONE OF THE FRIENDS DECIDED TO
REPORT THE INCIDENT TO THE LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM AND
THE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT DECLINED
TO RESPOND TO THE LOCATION OR TO
TAKE A REPORT STATING NO ABUSE
OF THE OLDER ADULT HAD OCCURRED.
IN ANOTHER RECENT CASE OUR
OFFICE RECEIVED A REPORT OF A
VIDEO BEING TAKEN BY CERTIFIED
NURSING ASSISTANT DURING CARE IN
A NURSING HOME.
TO SEE AN AIDS WERE PRESIDENT
CNA ONE TOOK THE VIDEO OF A
NAKED MALE RESIDENT DURING CARE
AND THE VIDEO WAS POSTED TO
FACEBOOK.
SEE AN EIGHT TO WATCHED BUT DID
NOT REPORT THIS TO ANYONE.
LAW ENFORCEMENT DID RESPOND TO
THIS CASE AND THE SEA IN A
PROTECT TOOK THE VIDEO PLAYED
OUT TO MISDEMEANOR INVASION OF
PRIVACY.
THE CNA WHO OBSERVE THE VIDEO
BEING TAKEN WAS NOT GUILTY A
FAILURE TO REPORT ELDER ABUSE
BECAUSE THE LAW DOES NOT
SPECIFICALLY INCLUDE THIS OF
ELDER ABUSE.
THIS BILL IF PASSED WOULD MAKE
THIS CRIME CLEAR.
VIOLATING AN ELDER DEPENDENT
ADULTS RIGHTS THROUGH CAPTURING
THEIR IMAGE AND OR DISSEMINATING
ON SOCIAL MEDIA IS A CRIME AND
THE LAW SHOULD BE CLEAR THAT
THIS ACTIVITY DEFINITIVELY
CONSTITUTES ELDER ABUSE.
THEIR EMPLOYMENT TERMINATED DUE
TO THESE REPREHENSIBLE CASES
THERE IS NOTHING STOPPING THEM
FROM MOVING ON TO ANOTHER
FACILITY AND DOING IT YET AGAIN.
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEMENTIA AND
OTHER COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENTS CAN
BE EXTREMELY SUSCEPTIBLE TO
ABUSE FOR PREDATORY CAREGIVERS.
OUR LAWS FOR PROTECTING THIS
VULNERABLE POPULATION HAVE NOT
KEPT PACE WITH OUR TECHNOLOGY.
AND WITH THIS COMMITTEE SUPPORT
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION YOU
CAN CHANGE LESS.
THANK YOU.
A ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT.
OUR STATE OMBUDSMAN JOE
RODRIGUEZ HAD TO LEAVE EARLY BUT
HE'S ONE OF HIS RIP US APART ON
THE RECORD.
THANK YOU.
HILL SOIL FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING IN STRONG
SUPPORT THIS IS AN AGREE JUST
ACT THAT.
SHOULD CLEARLY BE FOUND IN THE
PENAL CODE.
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
KEN NICE FROM PARTS OF MATTER
NAPA CALIFORNIA ARE CFE OWNER
AND OPERATOR AND A MEMBER OF
SIXPENCE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
KAREN JONES LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN SERVICES OF SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY IN A MEMBER OF CHO
KHOA STRONG SUPPORT.
NIKKI LOWER PROGRAM COORDINATOR
ON THAT'S MEN. SENECAS HIM
BENITO. BY THE TIME RESIDENTS
GET TO A SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY HERE ASSISTED LIVING
THEY'VE ALREADY LOST.
SO MUCH THERE'D NOT IN THEIR
HOME WITH THEIR THINGS.
ALL THEY HAVE IS THEIR DIGNITY.
AND THAT HAPPENS ALL THE TIME
IT'S BAD ENOUGH SEEN STAFF.
HUMILIATING RESIDENTS.
ACTUALLY FELL MATT AND POST IT
SHOULD BE A CRIME.
JACK CLINTON'S AND WE ARE PEOPLE
TO YEAR WEIGHT THE CAPITAL THAT
RESPONSE THING.
ARE A A RP STRONGER SUPPORT
IF YOU.
MARY KAY WILLIAMS LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN SACRAMENTO IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
I ALSO HAVE A FATHER WHO'S
NINETY EIGHT YEARS OLD AND LONG
TERM CARE.
AND I OFFERED THOUGHT THINK THAT
FITS.
AS YOUR FATHER OR YOUR MOTHER.
THANK YOU.
MIKE MONTGOMERY CONGRESS
CALIFORNIA SENIOR SHAMING AT
SENIOR SHOULD BE A CRIME VOTE I.
TONY CHIQUITO WITH CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING REFORM
THIS BILL ADDRESSES A VERY.
HEATHER HARRISON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSISTED LIVING
ASSOCIATION WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION AT THIS POINT
WHERE CERTAINLY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE CONCEPT WERE WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS ON
SOME OF THE DETAILS TO AVOID.
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
YOU.
GEN ANTHONY IT'S CALIFORNIA WE
ALSO DO NOT HAVE A POSITION ON
THIS BILL THAT ALSO SUPPORT THE
CONCEPT AND AND WORKING WITH
OTHERS OFFICE IN THE SPONSORS.
THANK YOU.
BUT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY LET'S OF RETURNED. HEAD
YEAH TAUGHT HUNDRED AREAS THAT.
WELL IS THERE IS THERE ANY
COMMENTS OR A MOTION WELL I MEAN
THAT'S.
HOW YOU ARE TO DID NOT A DEBATE
NORMALLY THE MOTION OUR OKAY?
WE CANNOT THAT'S OUR YEAH THE
MOTION THIS IS I HAVE THE FLOOR
PARTS.
.
YOU NO I'M I'M JUST YOU KNOW I
WAS GONNA SAY PISSED OFF I GUESS
I CAN SAY THAT ON THE MICROPHONE
ARSES SAID ENOUGH YEAH. OF I
THINK IT'S.
CERTAINLY.
IT GRIEVES ME TO TO TO KNOW AND
THAT NOT TO REALIZE AND
RECOGNIZE THAT. PEOPLE ARE DOING
THIS.
TO OUR SENIORS
TWO VERY VULNERABLE INDIVIDUAL.
AND I WAS REMINDED OF.
I THINK SHE WAS THE ACTRESS
THAT TOOK A PICTURE OF A LADY AT
A GM.
YES SHE LOST HER JOB AND ALL
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS BUT THERE
WAS NOTHING DONE CRIMINALLY.
THAT COULD BE DONE I THINK THAT
AGAIN WITH THIS WITH THE SAME
MALICE WHICH I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT A PERSON IS DOING THIS.
ANY OTHER WAY BUT BEING VERY
MEAN SPIRITED WITH MALICE AND
FORETHOUGHT TO. TO YOU KNOW TO
HUMILIATE THE MODES MARVELOUS
TALKING ABOUT OUR SENIORS.
YOU NO I I SUPPORT TO BE A ONE
PERCENT AND PLEASE ADD ME AS A
CO AUTHOR.
OF THE BILL.
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT THIS
NEEDS TO BE UP AND LAW IN STATUE
TO MAKING SURE THAT NO ONE HAS
TO GO THROUGH THEIR SINCE IN A
CLEAR MESSAGE.
A CLEAR MESSAGE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OF AND SO WE
DO HAVE BUT THE SUMMER GIPSON
WITH THE MOTION TO PASS ON TO
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY IS OUR
SECOND.
ALRIGHT.
ANY OTHER COMMENT FROM MEMBERS.
THEY GET THAT I THINK IS A RUBIO
AND THANK YOU UP TO THE
OMBUDSMAN'S FOR OUT. OF THE
TELLING US THE STORIES BY KNOW
THAT THEIR OF THOUSANDS MORE AND
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU I JUST
WANTED TO ADD THAT AS A SCHOOL
TEACHER I ALWAYS I I LOOKED AT
THIS AS A BULLYING. LA ISSUE AND
YOU KNOW WE GROW UP AND I CAN
BEAT OUT THE PERSON THAT WAS
PULLING ME AT ONE POINT AND YOU
KNOW OUR SENIORS DON'T. YOU KNOW
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ON BILL THE
BILL THE OTHER WAY I. AND I
HAVE.
JUST SO YOU KNOW.
BUT BUT YOU KNOW WHAT THE
SENIORS THAT THE THE POPULATION
UNFORTUNATELY IS GOING THE OTHER
WAY AND THERE'S NO WAY TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES ESPECIALLY WITHOUT
YOU KNOWING FOLKS WITH DEMENTIA.
OR ALZHEIMER'S THAT. IT'S BUT
ANYWAY THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SO WE HAVE A MOTION FROM SOME
MEMBER GIPSON SECONDED BY SOME
OF A GLORIA. TO PASS TO US IN
THE PUBLIC SAFETY ACOUSTICAL.
KALRA AYE KALRA AYE VOEPEL.
NO.
VOEPEL NOT VOTING ALLEN.
CABALLERO.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE.
SO THAT THAT MEASURE DOES PASS.
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ANY
OF THE MEMBERS WOULD NOT BODE.
AND WE HAVE ONE MORE BILL
AWAITING.
SHE'S ON HER WAY RIGHT NOW BUT
LET. AS MARMORA BUT.
NO ANY OTHER MISSED US RIGHT NOW
YEAH LET'S START WITH ITEM
NUMBER ONE. A AB NINETY FIFTY
FIVE. WE MOAN I THINK ONLY
ASSEMBLY GIPSON RIGHT.
BECAUSE I SEE YOU HAVE A BALANCE
OF SERVER GIVES HIM A SERVER
THAT WERE NOT A SUMMER RUBIO.
ALWAYS ALL MY ONESELF WHO IS NOT
SKIPPING SKIPPING ALLEN BECAUSE
I HEAR SO.
NO ONE'S ON.
YEAH.
AB NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE.
GLORIA I MEAN SCUSE ME GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE.
FIX THAT.
THAT PASSES ON A SIX ZERO VOTE.
ON ITEM NUMBER TWO.
AB TWO OH TWO FIVE.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE.
PASS ON A SIX ZERO VOTE.
ITEM THREE.
ACOSTA NAY BETWEEN ONE ON ONE.
AB TWENTY MY NO ONE.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE FAT PASS ON A SIX ZERO
VOTE.
ON ITEM FOR. AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
NINE CHIU ELDER DEPEND UPON
ADULT FINANCIAL ABUSE.
CABALLERO.
HOME.
GLORIA.
CHAIRMAN CAN I CLARIFY MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THERE SOME
DIRECTION PROVIDED TO THE OFFER
ON THIS BILL THAT'S CORRECT.
TO.
A NEW INDUSTRY TO THE COMMENTS I
MADE ITS WAY INTO MEMBERS MAIN
OF ABSOLUTELY AND IN ADDITION TO
THE. WORK THAT WE DID OVER IN IN
GETTING CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS
AND CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE BILL
APOLOGIES AT STEP OUT OF THEM OF
WHAT I.
GOOD I SAID I.
GLORIA I THINK YOU.
AND OF MISTER CHAIR I WOULD LIKE
TO I'M GOING TO CHANGE MY VOTE
TO AND I.
WITH THE ASSURANCES THAT THIS
WILL BE ADDRESSED ARE AND IF YOU
COULD.
KEEP ME POSTED ON THE CHANGES
BECAUSE IT'S.
LIKE I STATED BEFORE I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
OKAY SO THEN THAT.
PASSES OUT ON OF FOUR ZERO FOUR
ONE VOTE.
I BELIEVE.
FOR THE ONE FOUR TO ONE.
YES.
I'M ITEM.
WHY RUBIO WE JUST HEARD?
CISCO LE ITEM SIX OF IRWIN AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETEEN.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE.
RUBIO. RUBIO AYE THE PASSED ON A
SIX TO ZERO VOTE.
ITEM SEVEN REYES AB TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY FOUR.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE.
THAT PASSES ON A SIX ZERO VOTE.
ITEM EIGHT AB THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT CHIU.
WHICH MEANS HER.
CABALLERO.
SO THAT DOESN'T AFFORD.
FOUR WHAT FOUR ONE LITTLE
CLOSER.
FIVE FIVE OF SUPPLIES
REPUBLICAN.
AND SO DECEMBER FRIEDMAN IS
HERE.
PLEASE. SHE'S BEEN HERE. SOONER
PLUS TWO HOURS I PUT MY
APOLOGIES FEELING. THAT.
THIS IS THE HAVING TO LISTEN TO
ME I KNOW.
ITEM NINE A BE. THIRTY NINETY
EIGHT. SUMMER FRIEDMAN POLICE.
MANY HUGH I'LL BE VERY BRIEF MO
A MOTION. BY RUBIO SECOND BY
GIPSON PLEASE.
THIS BUILD JUST STRENGTHENS
REQUIREMENTS FOR RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITIES TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS.
PLANS AND TRAINING FOR ALL OF
THEIR STOP SO THAT WE CAN AVOID.
THE HORRIBLE PROBLEMS THAT
WE'VE HAD IN WILD FIRES WITH
PEOPLE BEING LEFT BEHIND IN
SOUTH NOT KNOWING WHAT TO DO
WITH PEOPLE IN THIS CARE
FACILITIES IT'S A COMMON SENSE
BILL AND I. URGE MY VOTE.
LOOKING AT MY NAME IS LAURIE
FURRY SENTIMENT ATTORNEY WITH
HANDSOME BRIDGE AND I REPRESENT
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY AROUND THE STATE.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSISTED LIVING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY NINETY EIGHT.
THIS IS A STRAIGHTFORWARD BELL
THAT MAKE SURE ALL STAFF OF
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY ARE TRAINED ON
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS PLAN.
THAT THROUGH QUARTERLY DRILLS
UNDER VARIED CIRCUMSTANCES THE
STAFF PRACTICE EXECUTION OF THE
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS PLANS AND
THE PLANS ARE REVIEWED EACH
YEAR.
RECENT AMENDMENTS GO EVEN
FURTHER TO REQUIRE CERTAIN
PROVISIONS IN THE PLANS.
FOR EXAMPLE REQUIRING
AVAILABILITY OF CERTAIN
EMERGENCY CONTACT INFORMATION TO
IDENTIFIED EVACUATION SITES
INCLUDING ONE OUTSIDE OF THE
IMMEDIATE AREA. RESIDENT
INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO STAFF
AND UP AVAILABILITY APPROPRIATE
SUPPLIES IF SHELTERING IN PLACE.
THE BILL APPROPRIATELY REFRAINS
FROM BEING TOO PRESCRIPTIVE AS
TO THE DETAILS OF THE PLANS.
RATHER THE BILL SPECIFIES THE
ISSUES THAT EACH PLAN MUST.
ADDRESS
HUNDREDS OF RCA FEES AND
THOUSANDS OF SEEING SENIORS WERE
SAFELY EVACUATED DURING THE
STATE'S RECENT WILD FIRES. AND
LEARNING FROM AND BUILDING UPON
THE RECENT SUCCESSFUL RESPONSE
TO UNPRECEDENTED EMERGENCY
CONDITIONS.
PASSAGE OF THIS BILL WILL HELP
RCF FEES AND THEIR STAFF
TO BE EVEN MORE PREPARED FOR
EMERGENCIES IN THE FUTURE. SO I
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND IRISH I'VE.
THANK YOU I'M ANYONE ELSE'S
SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MONICA MILLER EVERYTHING
ALZHEIMER'S GREATER LOS ANGELES
AND SUPPORT THINK IF.
JIM GROSS ABOUT THE COUNTY OF
SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
SUSAN TO MORRIS ON BEHALF OF THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION WERE IN
SUPPORT.
RECTANGLE REPRESENTING SIX BEDS
DIETING LAST FALL SMALL
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY FOR
THE ELDERLY SIX BEDS OR FEWER.
IN SUPPORT.
AND MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST JET
HAND DOWN EVERYTHING IS
CALIFORNIA PROD CO SPONSORS OF
THE BILL AND. YOUR SUPPORT.
KIM GUYS ARE CFE OWNER OPERATOR
AND SIX BED MEMBER AND SO STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS.
CAROL SO THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING IN SUPPORT.
EXCITED WHEN OPPOSITION.
BRING A BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
SUMMER FRIEDMAN EXCELLENT
VILLAGE LIKE CLOSE.
BECAUSE I KNOW WHAT THE SENATE
FLOOR MY DISTRICT NEXT TIME
AFTER THIS BILL PASSES ALL SLEEP
A LITTLE BETTER.
GREAT BUT THANK YOU SO MUCH JOB
BECAUSE TO EQUAL.
AND WE HAVE A MOTION BY SIMILAR
RUBIO SAID GOODBYE GIPSON. DO
PASSED TO HUMAN SERVICES.
KALRA.
I KALRA AYE VOEPEL.
WELL I ALLEN. CABALLERO.
GIPSON AYE GIPSON AYE GLORIA AYE
GLORIA AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE.
THE BILL PASSED STATE HERE THANK
YOU. AND WE ARE ADJOURNED THANK
EVERYBODY.